THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD MORNING EVERYONE IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE'RE GOING TO LIMIT
ALL NONESSENTIAL GATHERING
SENATE HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING IN FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THE IN COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE
ORDERS THE SENATE IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO OUR
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO.
ENSURE THE PUBLIC CONTINUES
SAYS HAVE ACCESS THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS- AS
EVERYONE KNOWS EVERYONE OF
THESE BILLS HAS HAD A PUBLIC
HEARING ALREADY- WHERE WE'VE
TAKEN TESTIMONY OR THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR TESTIMONY ON
BEFORE- BOTH FOR AN OPPOSITION
AND S WE'VE DONE THAT- FOR
EACH OF THESE MEASURES A LOT OF
FOLKS WHO FOLLOW THIS PROCESS
DON'T REALIZE THAT BUT THAT IS
HOW THE PROCESS WORKS. AS WE
COMPLY WITH THOSE ORDERS WERE
ALSO HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS IN THE CAPITAL- WE ARE
LIVE STREAMING THE HEARING
TODAY SO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
MEMBERS AND STAFF MY FOLLOW
ALONG. AS A REMINDER TO
EVERYONE- TODAY'S HEARING
CONSISTS ONLY OF ITEMS THAT ARE
ON THE SUSPENSE FILE ALL OF
THESE MEASURES AS I'VE SAID
I'VE ALREADY HAD A HEARING
ABOUT THIS COMMITTEE WITH THE
OPTION FOR PUBLIC TESTIMONY. AS
NOTED IN THE DAILY FILE THE
SUSPENSE HEARING IS A VOTE ONLY
HEARING WITH NO TESTIMONY AND
AGAIN THAT TO SOMEBODY'S
ALREADY TAKEN PLACE. I'D LIKE
TO THANK ALL OF MY FELLOW
SENATORS THEIR STAFFS AND MY
STAFF ON THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FOR ALL THEIR
ASSISTANCE AND THE WORK ON
THESE MEASURES AS WE GOT TO
THIS POINT. I'D ALSO LIKE TO
GIVE A SPECIAL THANK YOU TO A
VICE CHAIR SENATOR BATES AND
HER FISCAL STAFF FOR THEIR
AMAZING COOPERATION AND
COLLABORATION THROUGH THIS
DIFFICULT AND INTERESTING HERE-
BEFORE WE BEGIN I ALSO TO MAKE
A FEW ANNOUNCEMENTS ABOUT HOW
WE'LL PROCEED TO THE MEMBERS.
OF THE PUBLIC MEMBERS AND STAFF
CAN FOLLOW WILL BE MOVING TO
THE ALPHABET IN ORDER THAT WE
ARE MAKING ONE CHANGE I'M GOING
TO START WITH THE- THREE
ASSEMBLY SENATE- RESOLUTIONS
WHICH AT THE END OF YOUR BOOKS
MEMBERS SO. WILL WILL DISPENSE
WITH THE SENATE STUFF FIRST.
WE'RE GONNA GO ALPHABETICALLY
BY AUTHOR THEREAFTER WELL PAY
CLOSE ATTENTION. AS WE WILL
ONLY BE ADDRESSING MEMBERS MET
MEASURES THAT WILL BE UP FOR A
VOTE THIS MORNING. IF YOU DON'T
HEAR ME TAKE UP A PARTICULAR
MEASURE THAT BILL IS HELD UNDER
SUBMISSION. ON SUSPENSE NOW.
THERE IS ONE CAVEAT TO THAT-
STAY TUNED BECAUSE AT THE END
STAY FOR THE CREDITS WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE OUR MARVEL
CREDITS MOMENT BECAUSE AT THE
END I WILL READ A LIST OF BILLS
THAT ARE TWO YEAR BILLS. I'M
NOT GOING TO DO THAT AS WE GO
ALONG- I WILL READ THE LIST OF
TO YOUR BILLS AT THE END. OF
OUR CALENDAR- AND I MAKE ONE
COMMENT- ON THE TO YOUR BILL
SOME OF THEM HAVE BEEN. MADE TO
YOUR BILLS BASED ON THE
AUTHOR'S REQUEST SOME COMMITTEE
REQUEST AND SOME BASED ON THEIR
IMPLICATIONS RELATIVE TO THE
BUDGET ON THINGS THAT ARE
ONGOING BUDGET ISSUES. SO STAY
CLOSE ATTENTION ALL THE WAY TO
THE BITTER END- AS WE PROGRESS
ALL ANNOUNCED THE AUTHOR THE
MEASURE NUMBER AND PROVIDE A
BRIEF DESCRIPTION DESCRIPTION
OF ANY AMENDMENTS TO THE
MEASURE BEFORE WE TAKE THE
VOTE. WILL ALSO BE DOING STUFF
TO DO ROLL CALLS TO MOVE THINGS
QUICKLY ONCE WE ESTABLISH WITH
THOSE ROLL CALL VOTES ARE.
FOLLOWING THE HEARING WILL WITH
THE POSTING THE HEARING RESULTS
AND THE ACTIONS TAKEN ON EACH
MEASURE THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AT W. W. W. DOT S. A.
P. R. DOT SENATE DOT CA DOT GOV
SO AGAIN. AFTER THE HEARING
WILL POST ALL ACTIONS TAKEN ON
W. W. DOT S. A. P. R. DOT
SENATE DOT CA DOT GOV. IN
ADDITION FOR ANY BILLS THAT ARE
BEING AMENDED TODAY WILL BE
HOSTING AN ADDENDUM ANALYSIS.
WHICH INCLUDES A SUMMARY OF THE
AMENDMENTS AND THE REVISED
FISCAL IMPACTS OF THE AMENDED
BILL SO WE'RE GOING TO
ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
UNDER PORTANTINO I'M HERE
SENATOR BATES ARE PORTANTINO
HERE SENATOR BATES SENATE RATES
HERE SENATOR BRADFORD BRADFORD
HERE SENATOR JONES I'M HERE
JONES HERE CENTER KAMLAGER HERE
IN ORDER HERE'S LAYERED HERE
LAYERED HERE SENATOR REQUIRE
MCGUIRE HERE SEVEN MEMBERS ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE EVERYONE HERE NO
ONE IS FOR- PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY- SO WE ARE GOING TO GO
RIGHT TO OUR AGENDA I'M GONNA
ROLL CALL ON ALL THREE OF THOSE.
ONE RIGHT EXACTLY ALL RIGHT OUR
FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS IS S.
C. EIGHT TWO BY SENATOR ALLEN-
PUBLIC HOUSING- MR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE BEST
MOTION IS DUE. TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. FIFTY SENATE
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT NUMBER
TWO TO MOTIONS TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO
HI YOU KNOW I CENTER BATES.
BATES FIVE CENTER BRADFORD
BRADFORD TYSON- JONES JONES
FIVE CENTER KAMLAGER HI
KAMLAGER EYES CENTER LAYERED
ON. LATER I SENATE MCGUIRE.
WHERE ARE SEVEN VOTES AS WELL
AS OUT WILL MOVE ON TO CENTER
GLAZER S. C. A. FIVE ON UC
BOARD OF REGENTS STUDENT
MEMBERS. MOTION IS TO PASS AND
MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SECOND OF ALL OF THIS HAS
AMENDMENTS PER AUTHOR TO ADD CO
OFFICE. THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
THE SENATE CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT FIVE. A PORTANTINO I
KNOW BATES BATES AYE BRO
BRADFORD I'D JONES JONES HI
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER I LAYERED
HI LARRY FIVE MCGUIRE. ACQUIRE
ONLINE SEVENTY ZERO ACTUALIZADA
SEVEN IS HERE WE WILL MOVE ON
TO CENTER HERTZBERG SCA ONE ON
ELECTIONS REFERENDA MOTIONS TO
PASS. SENATE CONSTITUTIONAL
MOMENT ONE MOTIONS TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO
I YOU KNOW I CENTER BATES
BATESON- CENTER BRADFORD
BRADFORD II CENTER JONES JONES
NO CENTER KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER
EYES CENTER LAYERED HI THERE I
CENTER MCGUIRE ACQUIRE A POST
FIVE TO TWO. THE VILLAGE OUT
FIVE TO TWO ALL RIGHT WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO ASSEMBLY MEMBERS-
STARTING IN ALPHABETICAL ORDER
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUILAR
CURRY FIRST MEASURE IS AB
FOURTEEN CALIFORNIA ADVANCED
SERVICES FUND- THIS IS A ROLL
CALL VOTE IT IS A DO PASS
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN MOTIONS TO
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO AYE FORTINO AYE
BATES. BATES NO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD BY JONES JONES NO
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER HI LAYERED
HI THERE FIVE MCGUIRE BY BOTH
FIVE TO FILLINGS OUT FIVE TO
MOVING ON TO AGUIAR-CURRY AB
FORTY FIVE INDUSTRIAL HEMP
PRODUCTION TO DO PASS MOTION
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SOME
PEOPLE FORTY FIVE MOTIONS TO
PASS THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO I
BATES BATES HI CENTER BRADFORD.
BRADFORD BY CENTER JONES JONES
BY CENTER KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER I
CENTER LAYERED HI THERE I
CENTER MCGUIRE MCGUIRE SEVEN
ZERO FILLERS OUT SEVEN ZERO.
AND THAT WILL BECOME MORE
SUBSTITUTE ROLL CALL WHEN WE
GET TO OTHER SEVEN ZERO VOTES.
AGUIAR-CURRY AB SIX FOURTEEN ON
BIRD HABITAT IT IS A DO PASS
AND WE ARE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLE FOR AB FORTY FIVE SO
THAT BILLS APPROVED UNANIMOUSLY
SEVEN TWO ZERO. WE MOVE ON TO
AB EIGHT FORTY THREE ON BIOMASS
PROGRAM COMMUNITY CHOICE
AGGREGATORS AGAIN AGUIAR-CURRY-
THAT BILL IS OUT WITHOUT
OBJECTION. ON IN A ROLL CALL
WERE SUBSTITUTING THE MORAL
FROM AB FORTY FIVE THE BILL WAS
APPROVED UNANIMOUSLY PRESS TO
DO PASSED MOTION WHICH PASSES
UNANIMOUSLY ON A SEVEN OVER
BECAUSE WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLL CALL OF AB FORTY FIVE.
WELL BEYOND TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA AB THREE FOUR SEVEN
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE STEP
THERAPY- THIS IS A ROLL CALL
VOTE THE MOTION IS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS PER AUTHOR TO MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES TO REDUCE
COSTS PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FORTY SEVEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
CENTER PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO
EYES CENTER BATES. WELL BATES
NOW BY SENATOR BRADFORD
BRADFORD ICE CENTER JONES
CENTER KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER HI
CENTER LAYERED HI LATER BYE
SENATE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE HI VOTE
IS FIVE TO ONE OF BILLS OUT
FIVE TO ONE WILL MOVE ON AB
FIVE FIVE NINE IT IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION AND WE ARE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLL CALL FROM A. B.
FOURTEEN. HAS. THE NEW ARE FIVE
TO TWO. ALL RIGHT SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB FOURTEEN
SO THAT BILL IS OUT ON A ROLL
ON A VOTE OF FIVE TO PAY
ATTENTION MISTER JONES MOVING
ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMBLE
AGAIN AB SIX HUNDRED HATE CRIME
IMMIGRATION STATUS THIS IS A
ROLL CALL VOTE. AND IT IS A DO
PASS MOTION. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
HUNDRED THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
PORTANTINO AYE FORTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES SENATOR BRADFORD
BRADFORD HI CENTER JONES JONES
I CENTER KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER
EYES CENTER LAYERED ON EARLIER
I CENTER MCGUIRE MCGUIRE HI
THIRTY SIX TO ZERO THE FELLAS
OUT SIX TO ZERO MOVING ON A. B.
SIX TWENTY FIVE COUNTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER- WE IT IS TO DO PASS
AND WE'RE THE ROLL
CALL VOTE FROM AB FORTY FIVE SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE BILL WAS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS SEVEN.
ZERO VOTE AB ONE ZERO NINE FOR
SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND GENDER
IDENTITY DATA COLLECTION PILOT
PROGRAM THAT RECOMMENDATION IS
A DO PASS FOR THE MOTION IS TO
DO PASS WERE SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION AT THE
LIST OF APPROVED UNANIMOUSLY
SEVEN TO ZERO. AB ONE THIRTEEN
TWENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ARAMBULA ON PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES COUNTY LIAISON FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION IT IS A TO
PASS A MOTION AND WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB FORTY FIVE SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION THAT BILL IS OUT ON A
SEVENTY TWO ZERO VOTE. MOVING
ONTO ASSEMBLY MEMBER POWER CAN-
EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO DO PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS PER AUTHORED TO
REQUIRE THE REPORTING OF
SPECIFIC TYPES OF PROGRAMS AND
IT IS A ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN THIRTY ONE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO
HI PORTANTINO I CENTER BATES
SENATOR BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE
CENTER JONES SENATOR KAMLAGER
HI KAMLAGER BYE CENTER EARLIER
I CENTER MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
VOTE IS FIVE TWO ZERO THAT
PHYLLIS OUT. FIVE TWO ZERO- SO
WE ARE MOVING ON TO IT A. B.
TEN THIRTY THREE SMALL EMPLOYER
FAMILY LEAVE- MEDIATION THIS IS
A TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS PER
AUTHOR TO SPECIFY THAT THE
PARTIES MAY VOLUNTARILY MEDIATE
OTHER CLAIMS. WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE INTO
THAT BILL IS OUT WITH A AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS ON A SEVEN ZERO.
VOTE MOVING ON TO POWER CAN AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY MONEY
TRANSMISSIONS CUSTOMER SERVICES
MOTIONS TO DO PASSED WITH A
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO INSTEAD
REQUIRE MONEY TRANSFER SERVICES
TO LIST A TOLL FREE NUMBER FOR
LIVE ASSISTANCE WITHOUT
OBJECTION THAT BILL IS THAT
WE'RE SUBSTANTIVE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FORTY FIVE TO THAT BILL
IS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO. A. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX POWER CAN ON
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICE
PROVIDERS CONFIDENTIAL PERSONAL
INFORMATION. THAT THE MOTION IS
TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS PER
AUTHOR TO REDUCE THE FREQUENCY
OF POSTS COURSE A REVISIONS AND
MAKE TECHNICAL CHANGES AND
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE THE COURSE
REVISION CONTINGENT UPON
FINDING. THAT BILL WITHOUT
OBJECTION IS OUT ON A WORKSHOPS
IN THE ROLE FROM AB FOURTEEN SO
THAT BILL WILL BE OUT ON A FIVE
TO VOTE WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NO- AB FIFTEEN TWELVE ON
CARNEGIE STATE VEHICULAR
RECREATION AREA ALAMEDA TESTS
EXPANSION. IN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS WITH AMENDMENTS PER
OFFERED TO REMOVE THE
RESTRICTIONS ON THE USE OF
FUNDS AND WITHOUT OBJECTION
THAT WERE SUBSTANTIVE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE FOURTEEN SO THAT BILL
WILL BE OUT ON A FIVE TO VOTE
WITH THE REPUBLICAN. MEMBERS
VOTING. NOW MOVING ON TO MISS
BENNETT A SO SIX. COURT ACCESS
MOTIONS TO PASS AND WE ARE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FORTY FIVE. US WITHOUT
OBJECTION A BILL WAS APPROVED
UNANIMOUSLY. SEVEN TWO ZERO. AB
EIGHT NINE SIX CAL JAM
COLLECTION UNIT- THE MOTION IS
TO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR TO EXPAND CAL GEMS
EXISTING TAX LIEN AUTHORITY IN
LIEU OF PROVIDING NEW WITH
ARTISTS. WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE'RE GONNA SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE FOURTEEN- SO
THAT BILL WILL BE APPROVED ON A
VOTE OF FIVE TO TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW. MISTER
BENNETT AGAIN HAS A BEEF NINE
FOUR ONE FARMWORKERS SYSTEMS
RESOURCE CENTERS- THIS IS A
ROLL CALL VOTE ON THE MOTION IS
WITH AMENDMENTS PER AUTHORED A
CALF ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE FORTY ONE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO AYE
CENTER BATES SENATOR BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE SENATOR JONES
SENATOR KAMLAGER KAMLAGER HI
CENTER LAYERED HI EARLIER I
CENTER MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE VOTE
IS FIVE TWO ZERO. THAT FILLS
FIVE TWO ZERO WILL MOVE ON TO
MISTER BENNETT AB TEN FIFTY ONE
MEDIC CAL SPECIALLY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES THIS IS- WITH
THE MOTION IS WITH AMENDMENTS
PER AUTHORED TO STRIKE
REQUIREMENTS CREATE A
STANDARDIZED CONTRACT
TEMPLATES. AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WERE SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB FORTY FIVE SO
THAT BILL WAS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS SEVEN ZERO VOTE.
WE'RE MOVING TO MISTER BERMAN
WE HAVE AB THIRTY SEVEN
ELECTIONS VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS
THE MOTION IS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS PER AUTHOR TO REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF BALLOT DROP OFF
LOCATIONS FOR SMALL
JURISDICTIONS. AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE'RE SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB FOURTEEN
TO THAT BILL WAS APPROVED ON A
FIVE TO VOTE WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NOW MOVING ON AB SEVEN
NINETY SIX VOTER REGISTRATION
CALIFORNIA NEW VOTER PROGRAM-
THE MOTION IS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS FOR AUTHOR TO DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES AND ADDRESS CHAPTER IN
ISSUES- WITHOUT OBJECTION WERE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FOURTEEN. THAT BILL WAS
APPROVED ON A VOTE OF FIVE TO
TWO WITH REPUBLICANS. VOTING NO.
ALL RIGHT WE ARE MOVING TO AB
NINE TWENTY EIGHT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AT T. PATHWAYS. AND G.
E. REQUIREMENTS BY MISTER
BERAN- THIS BILL IS-
RECOMMENDATION AS- A MEMBER TIM
TO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS PER
AUTHORED TO PROVIDE A UNIT CAP
FOR THE SINGULAR GENERAL.
EDUCATION PATHWAY AND MODIFY
COMMITTEE AND MODIFY COMMITTEE
MEMBERSHIP. WITHOUT OBJECTION
RECEPTION THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
FORTY FIVE AND SO THAT BILL IS
OUT AS AMENDED ON WITH A SEVEN
TWO ZERO. VOTE MR BERMAN ALSO
IS AB ELEVEN ELEVEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE COURSE REMEMBERING
SYSTEMS IT HAS THEM IT IS A TO
PASS FOR THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR
TO EXTEND IMPLEMENTATION TIME
FRAMES WITHOUT OBJECTION I'M
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FORTY FIVE. SO THAT BILL
WAS APPROVED UNANIMOUSLY SEVEN
TO ZERO. MR BERMAN AS AB TWELVE
NINETEEN NATURAL HERITAGE
PRESERVATION TAX CREDIT ACT OF
TWO THOUSAND TO DO PASS. MOTION
AND I WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUBSTANTIVE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
FORTY FIVE SO THAT'S BILLS
APPROVED UNANIMOUSLY SEVEN TWO
ZERO. MR BERMAN AS AB THIRTEEN
FORTY SIX AIR POLLUTION SMALL
OFF ROAD ENGINES. THERE ARE
MEMBERS TO REQUIRE A R. B. TO
CONSIDER CERTAIN FACTORS IN
DETERMINING TECHNICAL LOGICAL
FEASIBILITY. AND SO THAT BILL
IS WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL
CALL OF AB FOURTEEN. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION THAT BILL WAS
APPROVED ON A VOTE OF FIVE TO
TWO WAS REPUBLICANS VOTING NO
MOVING TO MISTER BIGELOW AB
SEVEN SEVEN NINE PEACE OFFICERS
DEPUTY SHERIFFS WE'RE GONNA
TAKE A ROLL CALL ON THAT VOTE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SEVENTY
NINE MOTIONS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO.
HI YOUR PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR
BATES. BATES BY SENATOR
BRADFORD. BRADFORD ICE CENTER
JONES JONES ICE CENTER KAMLAGER
SENATOR LAYERED HI LARRY I
CENTER MCGUIRE FIRE FIVE OF SIX
TO ZERO THAT PHYLLIS OUT SIXTY
ZERO. GOING TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM AB SEVEN TWENTY ONE ON
COVENANTS AND RESTRICTIONS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS A TO PASS
A MOTION AND WE'RE GOING TO
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUBJECT TO
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB FOURTEEN
TO THAT BILL. IS APPROVED ON A
VOTE OF FIVE TO TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING IS NOW
MOVING ON A BALLOON AB ONE
THOUSAND NINE FARM TO SCHOOL
FOOD HAVE PROGRAM. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS PER
AUTHOR TO CLARIFY DEFINITIONS
OF POT UPDATE AND IT THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE STRUCTURE
AND MODIFY THE IMPLEMENTATION
TIMELINE WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
ROLL CALL VOTE ON ONE THOUSAND
NINE. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE ZERO
ZERO NINE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
CENTER PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO
I CENTER BATES SENATOR
BRADFORD. BRADFORD HIGH CENTER
JONES SENATOR KAMLAGER HI
KAMLAGER EYES CENTER LAYERED HI
THERE HIGHS AND REQUIRE WHY ARE
AYE WE HAVE FIVE TO ZERO A
BILLS OUT FIVE ZERO MOVING ON
THE A. B. TEN SIXTY SIX- NOT
THE BATTLE OF HASTINGS BUT THE
BILL TEN SIXTY SIX ON FRESH
WATER RECREATION SITE WATER
QUALITY MONITORING IT IS A TO
PASS A- MOTION AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE'RE GONNA
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB FORTY FIVE SO THAT BILL IS
OUT SEVEN. ZERO AB ELEVEN
TWENTY SIX COMMISSION ON STATE
HATE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS FOR
THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
COMMISSIONERS AND MAKE THE
OPERATION OF THE COMMISSION
CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION. WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB ELEVEN TWENTY SIX.
I'M A SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE FOURTEEN AND SO THAT
BILL WAS APPROVED ON A VOTE OF
FIVE TO TWO. WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NOW. AB FOR TWELVE
EIGHTY TWO ON VETERINARY
MEDICINE BLOOD BANKS FOR
ANIMALS. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
FOR THE MEMBERS PER AUTHORED TO
PROVIDE GENERAL FUND
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITIES THAT
OBJECTION I'M SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE
SO THAT BILL IS OUT IN ANNA SUI
SEVEN. TWO ZERO. MOVING TO A
**** **** BATH- AB SIX SIX. IS
RESEARCH ON COASTAL LANDSLIDES
AND EROSION SAN DIEGO COUNTY IT
IS A DO PASS MOTION AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION OF SUBSTANTIVE ROLL
CALL FROM AB FORTY FIVE SO THAT
BILL WILL PASS UNANIMOUSLY
SEVEN TWO ZERO. ALSO ON AB
TWELVE FIFTEEN UC ADMISSIONS
POLICIES AND PROTOCOLS THE TO
PASS AND WITHOUT OBJECTION OF
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FORTY FIVE BILLS APPROVED
UNANIMOUSLY SEVENTY TWO ZERO AB
THIRTEEN NINETY STATE LAND
SCHOOL AND LOU- LANDS. IT IS A
DO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR TO MAKE A CLARIFYING
CHANGE- AND WITHOUT OBJECTION
I'M SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL
FROM AB FORTY FIVE THE BILL IS
APPROVED ON UNANIMOUS VOTE
SEVEN ZERO. MOVING TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURKE- EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY
CALIFORNIA JOBS PLAN ACTIVE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- THE MOTION
IS TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS TO
ADD A DEFINITION AND MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES. THAT
OBJECTION OF SUBSTANCE THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE FOURTEEN- THAT
BILL WAS APPROVED ON A VOTE OF
FIVE TO TWO WITH REPUBLICANS.
VOTING NOW- BURKE AB WELL SIXTY
ONE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
INCENTIVE PROGRAM. MOTIONS TO
PASS FOR THE MEMBERS FOR
AUTHORED AT ITS WHOLE AUTHOR
AND THEN TO CONTRACT OUT
SPECIFIED RESEARCH TO UC OR
CSU. WITHOUT OBJECTION CONCEPTS
IN THE ROLL CALL FROM AB FORTY
FIVE THAT BILL IS OUT SEVEN TWO
ZERO PM SELECT. MOVING ON TO
CALL THEIR OWN AB SIX NINETEEN
AIR QUALITY PUBLIC HEALTH PLAN
FOR COUNTY USE. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS PER
AUTHOR TO DELETE THE COUNTY.
TASK FORCE AND ADD A CO AUTHOR
WITHOUT OBJECTION OF SUBSIDY IN
THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY
FIVE. THE BILL WAS APPROVED
UNANIMOUSLY SEVEN TWO ZERO AB
SIX SEVEN ZERO ON CHILD ABUSE
OR NEGLECT DEPENDENT MINOR NON
MINOR PARENTS TECHNICIANS
MOTIONS TO PASS WITHOUT
OBJECTION I'M SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE
SO THE BILL IS APPROVED ON A
SEVEN TWO ZERO UNANIMOUS VOTE.
AB TWELVE FIFTY ON WATER AND
SEWER SYSTEMS CONSOLIDATION OF
SERVICE IS A DO PASS AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION I'M
SUBSTANTIVE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
FORTY FIVES THAT BILLS APPROVED
ANY UNANIMOUS. SEVEN ZERO. VOTE
PROVING ON TO THIS MEMBER AB
SEVEN FOUR AIR POLLUTION IN
CENTER PROGRAM ELIGIBILITY- IT
IS A DO PASS WITH THE MEMBERS
PER AUTHOR TO DETERMINE SHARED
ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES
BETWEEN A. R. P. AND L. W. D.
EIGHT. WITHOUT OBJECTION-
SUBSIDY IN THE ROCK FOR MAYBE
FOURTEENTH SO THAT BILLS
APPROVED ON A VOTE OF FIVE TO
TWO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NOW. AB NINE THREE SEVEN ON
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT- IS A
TO PASS A MOTION. AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION I'M SUBSTITUTE IN THE
ROLL CALL OF AB FORTY FIVE. SHE
ME I'M CERTAIN THE ROLL CALL
FROM AB FOURTEEN SO THAT BILL
WAS APPROVED ON A VOTE OF FIVE
TO TWO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NOW. AB TWELVE SEVENTY SIX
SINGLE USE FOOD ACCESSORIES.
MOTIONS TO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS
TO STRIKE NAPKINS FROM THE
DEFINITION OF SINGLE USE FOOD
WEAR ACCESSORIES. WITHOUT
OBJECTION I'M SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FOURTEEN TO
THAT BILLS APPROVED ON
UNANIMOUS. FIVE TO VOTE WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO CERVANTES
WERE MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES AB SEVEN SIX
FOUR VICTIM INTIMIDATION VISIT
TO PASS MOTION WITHOUT
OBJECTION OF SUBSTANCE THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE SO
THAT BILL IS APPROVED
UNANIMOUSLY SEVEN TWO ZERO. AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID AND CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS MOTIONS TO PASS WITH A
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO AVOID
CHAPTER IN ISSUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION OF SUBSTANTIVE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE SO
THAT BILL IS OUT UNANIMOUSLY
SEVEN TWO ZERO. AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN PERINATAL HEALTH IT
IS A TO PASS MOTION WITHOUT
OBJECTION OF SUBSTANTIVE BROKE
OFF FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE THE
BILL IS OUT UNANIMOUSLY SEVEN
ZERO. MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAO. AB THIRTY NINE
CALIFORNIA CHINA CLIMATE
INSTITUTE MOTIONS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE THE
INSTITUTE SUBJECT TO THE
AVAILABILITY OF PRIVATE FUNDS-
WITHOUT OBJECTION I'M
SUBSTITUTING THE MOTION FOR A
BI FOURTEEN. TO THAT BILLS
APPROVED ON A VOTE OF FIVE TO
TWO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NOW. A. B. SIX NINE SEVEN GOOD
NEIGHBOR AUTHORITY PROGRAM IS
THE MOTION IS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS PER AUTHOR TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES AND THIS IS
A ROLL CALL THOSE SENATE BILL
SIX NINETY SEVEN THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES.
THE LADY SENATOR BRADFORD
CENTER BRADFORD BY SENATOR
JONES CENTER KAMLAGER HI
KAMLAGER HI CENTER LAYERED HI
THERE I SENATOR MCGUIRE WIRE
FIVE FIVE TO ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT FIVE TWO ZERO. MOVING ON TO
AB TWELVE FORTY SEVEN CRIMINAL%
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS IT IS A
DO PASS MOTION AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION I'M SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE.
FOR THAT BILL IS OUT
UNANIMOUSLY SEVEN TWO ZERO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN HAS AB
THREE FIVE SIX ON FLUOROSCOPY
TEMPORARY PERMITS IT IS A
MOTION WITH AMENDMENTS PER
AUTHORED TO ADD ADDITIONAL
CRITERIA TO QUALIFY FOR
TEMPORARY PERMIT. WITHOUT
OBJECTION I'M SEVENTEEN ROLL
CALL FROM AB FORTY FIVE THAT
BILL WAS APPROVED UNANIMOUSLY
ON A VOTE OF SEVEN TO ZERO.
LIVING TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU
HE HAS AB TWO FIFTEEN ON
HOUSING ELEMENT VIOLATIONS IT
IS A DO PASS. MOTION AND WE'RE
GONNA TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE ON
TWO FIFTEEN. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
FIFTEEN MOTIONS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO
I WANT TO HELP BY CENTER BATES.
BATES KNOWS CENTER BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE CENTER JONES.
JONES KNOWS CENTER KAMLAGER.
KAMLAGER I CENTER LAYERED HI
LARRY I CENTER MCGUIRE SO IS.
FORTY TWO. THE VOTERS FORTY TWO
SETTLERS OUT MOVING ON TWO
EIGHTY FOR EIGHTY ONE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY MILITARY
EQUIPMENT THE MOTION IS A DO
PASS WITH THE MEMBERS PER
AUTHORED TO REVISE THE LIST OF
MILITARY EQUIPMENT AND
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS REDUCE
LOCAL WORKLOAD AND ESTABLISH A
SEPARATE PROCESS FOR STATE
AGENCIES AND AMENDMENTS TO MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES THAT
OBJECTION OF SUBSTITUTE IN THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FOURTEEN SO
THAT BILL WAS APPROVED ON A
FIVE TO VOTE. WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO AB FIVE TWENTY FIVE
OFFSHORE WIND ENERGY GENERATION
MOTIONS TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS
PER AUTHORED TO REQUIRE
PERMITTING ROAD MAP IN LIEU OF
WORKING GROUP AND ADD A SUNSET
AND ALSO AMENDMENTS TO REQUIRE
THE PLAN TO INCLUDE CERTAIN
IMPACTS EXTEND TIMELINES AND
MAKE OTHER CHANGES WITHOUT
OBJECTION OF SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE
SO THAT WAS APPROVED.
UNANIMOUSLY.
SEVEN TWO ZERO.
HOLD ON ONE SECOND. OKAY SO WE
ARE ON AB SIX SIX SIX SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT MOTIONS TO PASS AND
I'VE WITHOUT OBJECTION-
SUBSTRING THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FORTY FIVE THAT BILLS
APPROVED UNANIMOUSLY SEVEN TWO
ZERO I WOULD CHIU HAS AB TWELVE
FIFTY NINE CRIMINAL PROCEDURE
MOTION TO VACATE- IT IS A DO
PASS MOTION AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION- UBSIDY IN THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE FOURTEEN MINUTES
SO THAT BILL PASSES FIVE TWO
TWO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO.
CHIU HAS A COMMITTEE CAPE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING BILL AB
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FORCE THE
HOUSING OMNIBUS BILL IT IS A TO
PASS AND WE'RE SUBSTITUTING
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE SO.
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR PASSES
SEVEN. TWO ZERO. VEON TO COOLEY
AB FOUR SEVEN TWO NINE CAMPSITE
RESERVATIONS BOUGHT SOFTWARE
AND SERVICES IT IS A DO PASS.
MOTION AND WITHOUT OBJECTION
I'M SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE BILLS
APPROVED UNANIMOUSLY SEVEN TWO
ZERO. COOLEY AB TEN NINETY FIVE
AFFORDABLE RENTAL AND OWNER
OCCUPIED HOUSING MOTIONS DO
PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS TO MAKE
A CLARIFYING CHANGE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION I'M SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE
SO THAT BILL IS OUT SEVEN TWO
ZERO. UNANIMOUSLY COOPER FOR ME
ON THIS ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER
AB THREE SIXTEEN STATE EMPLOYEE
PAY EQUITY UNDER REPRESENTED
GROUPS IT IS A DO PASS. MOTION
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION INCEPTION
THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY
FIVE THE BILL WAS APPROVED
UNANIMOUSLY SEVEN TWO ZERO. AB
THREE FIVE NINE PHYSICIANS AND
SURGEONS LICENSING AND
CONTINUING EDUCATION- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS PER AUTHOR TO RECAST
THE EXEMPTION FOR OUT OF STATE
LICENSEES. WITHOUT OBJECTION
I'M SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE SO A. B.
THREE FIVE NINE IS APPROVED
SEVENTY TWO ZERO. AB TEN
SEVENTY ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE JEFF
RESTRICTION EXEMPTIONS
ADVERTISING ELLIS IS A DO PASS
A MOTION WITHOUT OBJECTION-
SUBSTITUTE ROLL CALL FROM AB
FORTY FIVE. THAT BILLS APPROVED
UNANIMOUSLY. SEVEN TWO ZERO.
ALL RIGHT WE ARE MOVING TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY A. B.
ELEVEN OH THREE AGRICULTURAL
PAST PROGRAM DISASTER ACCESS TO
FARM LANDS- THE MOTIONS TO PASS
WITH AMENDMENTS PER AUTHOR TO
NARROW SCOPE AND MAKE A
CLARIFYING CHANGE WITHOUT
OBJECTION- TIME SEVENTEEN ROLL
CALL FROM AB FORTY FIVE SO THAT
THOSE APPROVED UNANIMOUSLY
SEVEN. TWO ZERO. HAVING ONTO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY A. B. SIX
OH FOUR R. M. R. A. ACCRUED
INTEREST IT IS A DO PASS.
MOTION AND WITHOUT OBJECTION
I'M SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE SO THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
SEVEN TO ZERO. OTE DALY HAS AB
SEVEN EIGHTY ONE FLOOD CONTROL
PROJECTS COUNTY OF ORANGE SUB
PENSION FUNDS IT IS A DO PASS
MOTION WITHOUT OBJECTION I'M
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FORTY FIVE. SAMPLES OUT
SEVEN TWO ZERO AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY THREE MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING PROGRAMS EXPENDITURE
LOAN PRO PROCEEDS. IT IS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION I'M SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE
SO AB FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE
PASSES SEVEN TWO ZERO. AB
FIFTEEN SIXTY ON STUDENT
COMMUTING DEVICE SURVEY IT IS A
MOTION BY THE MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES WITHOUT OBJECTION OF
SUBSTANCE THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FORTY FIVE SO THAT BILLS
OUT. SEVEN TWO ZERO. MOVING
ONTO ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLORA AB
FIVE SEVEN NINE CALIFORNIA
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
PURCHASES IT IS TO DO PASS.
MOTION AND WITHOUT OF SUBSIDY
THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY
FIVE. SO A. B. FIVE SEVEN NINE
PASSES SEVEN ZERO. AB TEN
TWENTY THREE ON CONTRACTORS AND
SUBCONTRACTORS RECORDS
PENALTIES. THERE IS A MOTION
WITH AMENDMENTS PER AUTHOR TO
MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES AND
WE'RE GONNA DO A ROLL CALL VOTE
ON A. B. TEN TWENTY THREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN TWENTY THREE
TO MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
CENTER BATES SENATOR BRADFORD.
ST BRADFORD AYE CENTER JONES
JON SNOW KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I
CENTER LAYERED LAYERED HI
CENTER REQUIRE WIRE ON YOUR
FIVE TO ONE THE BILL IS OUT
FIVE TWO ONE MOVING ON TO AB
TWELVE TWELVE TWENTY ONE ON
CONSUMER WARRANTIES SERVICE
CONTRACTS. IT IS A MOTION WITH
AMENDMENTS TO EXCLUDE VEHICLE
SERVICE CONTRACTS SO WITH THAT
AMENDMENT- WE ARE WILL
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB FORTY FIVE WITHOUT OBJECTION
TO THAT BILL AS AMENDED
DISAPPROVED SEVEN. ZERO OF FONG
HAS AB THREE VEHICLE EXHIBITION
OF SPEED. IT IS A TO PASS A
MOTION AND WITHOUT OBJECTION
I'M SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL
FROM AB FORTY FIVE. THAT BILLS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
SEVEN. TO ZERO. BRING ON TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN AB
FIVE NINE TO FOSTER YOUTH
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING. IS A TO
PASS A MOTION AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION I'M SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE.
SO AB FIVE NINETY TWO PASSES
UNANIMOUSLY SEVEN ZERO. AB SIX
FOUR TWO WILDFIRES IT IS A TO
PASS RECORD MOTION. AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION I'M SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE
SO AB SIX FOUR TWO PASSES
UNANIMOUSLY SEVEN. ZERO AB
EIGHT THREE EIGHT STATE HOUSING
LAW COMPLAINT DRIVEN
INSPECTIONS IS A DO PASS MOTION
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION OF
SUBSTANCE THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FOURTEEN. SO THAT BILL
WAS APPROVED ON A FIVE TO VOTE
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW. AB
TEN TWENTY DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE ACCESS AND INFORMATION
MOTIONS TO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS
PER AUTHOR TO DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION AND MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES. WITHOUT
OBJECTION OF SUBSTANCE THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE TO
THAT BILL PASSES SEVEN. TWO
ZERO AB ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION PLAN
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUBJECT IN
THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
FOURTEEN. THAT BILLS APPROVED
ON A VOTE OF FIVE TO TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS. VOTING NO MOVING
ON TO MEMBER GAVE HERE AB FIFTY
SEVEN. LAW ENFORCEMENT HATE
CRIMES- THEM IT IS THE MOTION
IS TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS TO
MAKE THE POST COURSE
DEVELOPMENT CONTINGENT UPON
FUNDING- WITHOUT OBJECTION I'M
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB FORTY FIVE SAID THAT BILL
WAS APPROVED UNANIMOUSLY. SEVEN
TWO ZERO. AB SIXTY ONE BUSINESS
PANDEMIC RELIEF- THE MOTION IS
TO PASS WITH THE MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR TO ALLOW THE A. B. C. TO
CANCEL TEMPORARY CATERING
AUTHORIZATIONS. THAT OBJECTION
I'M SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE THAT BILL
WAS APPROVED UNANIMOUSLY SEVEN
ZERO. AB SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN ON
REENACT INVERTED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS- THE MOTION IS TO
PASS FOR THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR
TO LIMIT CONVERSIONS. TO
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING AND
DELAY IMPLEMENTATION AND ALSO
AMENDMENTS TO ADD A CO AUTHOR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE
SUBSTANCE THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FORTY FIVE- SO THAT BILL
WILL BE OUT ON A SEVEN ZERO
UNANIMOUS VOTE. AB NINE SEVEN
SEVEN HOMELESS MANAGEMENT
INFORMATION SYSTEM DATA
REPORTING. THE MOTIONS TO PASS
FOR THE MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO
CLARIFY DATA REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS PROVIDE ONE YEAR
GRACE PERIOD. FOR REPORTING A
NEW PROGRAM TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
NINE SEVEN SEVEN WE WILL
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FORTY FIVE SAID THAT BILL
WILL PASS SEVEN TWO ZERO. A. B.
NINE EIGHT NINE ON HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT OFFICE OF
HOUSING APPEALS FUNCTION IS TO
PASS WITHOUT OBJECTION OF
SUBSTANCE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
FOURTEEN. THAT BILL WAS
APPROVED ON A VOTE OF FIVE TO
TWO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NOW. AB. THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR
RESILIENCY THROUGH I HAD A
STATE ACCOUNT THAT CAN FIGHT IN
EQUITY AFTER TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
MOTIONS TO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS
PER AUTHORED TO EXTEND THE TIME
LINE. TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
REQUIRED TO SAFEGUARD GUARDING
CALIFORNIA PLAN TO INCLUDE
SPECIFIED INFORMATION. AND MAKE
OTHER CHANGES. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THEMSELVES IN THE
ROLE KAUFER MAYBE FOURTEEN SO
THAT BILLS APPROVED ON A FIVE
TO VOTE WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NOW. AB FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO
HEALTH FACILITIES CRITICAL CARE
UNITS BED DESIGNATION PROGRAM
THAT IS A DO PASS MOTION
WITHOUT OBJECTION I'M
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FOURTEEN SO THAT BILLS
APPROVED ON A FIVE TO VOTE WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER HAS AB THREE
SEVEN NINE ON CONSERVATION
LANDS. IT IS A MOTION TO DO
PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS PER
AUTHOR TO LIMIT THE SCOPE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUBJECT IN
THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY
FIVE STEP BILL PASSES SEVEN.
ZERO WE ONTO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA AB THREE ONE
THREE. CIVIL SERVICE LIMITED
EXAM EXAMINATION AN APPOINTMENT
PROGRAM. MOTIONS TO PASS WITH
THE MEMBERS PER AUTHORED TO
REQUIRE STATE DEPARTMENTS TO
ADOPT THEIR OWN POLICY ON
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATIONS AND
MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION I'M
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB FORTY FIVE AND SO. AB
THIRTEEN THREE THIRTEEN IS OUT
SEVEN TWO ZERO. AB THREE SIXTY
SEVEN ON MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS. IT
IS MOTIONS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS PER AUTHOR TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES WE WILL TAKE
A ROLL CALL VOTE ON THREE SIX
SEVEN. ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
SIXTY SEVEN MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
CENTER PORTANTINO. I RUTINA I
SENATOR BATES. EIGHT SIZE
CENTER BRADFORD. BRADFORD ICE
CENTER JONES JONES VICE
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER ICE CENTER
LAYERED LAYER BY CINEMA HI R.
I. SEVEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
SEVEN TWO ZERO BUILDING ON A.
B. FOUR FIVE THREE SEXUAL
BATTERY CONDOM REMOVAL THIS IS
A DO PASSING WITHOUT OBJECTION
I'M SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE SO THAT
BILL IS APPROVED SEVEN TWO
ZERO. AB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE ON
SPOUSAL RAPE- THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS FOR
AUTHORED TO SPECIFY THAT
PROSECUTION IS ALLOWED UNDER
OATH CATEGORIES OF SHIMMY UNDER
OTHER CATEGORIES OF RATE FOR
SPOUSE OF A DISABLED PERSON IF
APPLICABLES WITHOUT OBJECTION
I'M SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE AND SO
THAT BILL IS OUT ON A SEVEN TWO
ZERO UNANIMOUS. VOTE.
YOU MUST
BE MAKING PROGRESS IN THE
ASSEMBLY BECAUSE THEY GOT TO
THE ELS- THIS IS YOUR THEY'RE
DONE. AB SIX TO EIGHT BREAKING
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT
INITIATIVES MOTIONS TO PASS
WITH THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
DELETE THE SUB COMMITTEE AND
MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES WITHOUT
OBJECTION I'M SUBSTANTIVE ROLL
CALL FROM AB FORTY FIVE SO THAT
BILL IS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO AB
TEN THIRTY SIX CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS ACT OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THE WITHOUT THEIR
MOTION IS TO PASS WITH THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO ADD
LEGISLATIVE INTENT AND TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES WITHOUT
OBJECTION OF SUBSEA THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE STEP
BILLS OUT. SEVEN TO ZERO.
MOVING ON TO. MOVING ON TO A BE
SIX SIXTY FOUR NINE OH FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON ON
ARREST PROPOSITIONAL ASPHYXIA
EMOTIONS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS PER AUTHOREDTO
REVISE THE DEFINITION OF
POSITIONAL ASPHYXIA WITHOUT
OBJECTION OF SECTION THE ROLL
CALL OF AB FOURTEEN TO THAT
BILL IS OUT FIVE TO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW MISTER
GIBSON HAS AB SIX FIVE ONE IN
DOWN THE CARE CEMETERY'S
MAINTENANCE AND FUNDS- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE I MANDATE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION OF SUB TO IN
THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY
FIVE THE BILL PASSES. SEVENTY
ZERO EIGHTY NINE FIVE EIGHT LAW
ENFORCEMENT GANGS THE MOTION IS
TO PASS WITHOUT OBJECTION OF
SECTION THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE.
FORTY FIVE LEVELS OUT SEVENTY.
TWO ZERO- AB FORTY EIGHT OR
MOVING ONTO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ AB FORTY EIGHT LAW
ENFORCEMENT KINETIC ENERGY
PROJECTILES AND CHEMICAL
AGENTS. MOTION IS TO PASS WITH
THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
CHANGE THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS CHANGE WHEN LESS
LETHAL WEAPONS MAY BE USED FOR
CROWD CONTROL. AND EXEMPTS
COUNTY DETENTION FACILITIES
THAT OBJECTION OF SUBSTANTIVE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FOURTEEN.
THAT BILLS APPROVED ON A VOTE
OF FIVE TO TWO WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NOW. AB SEVENTY FOUR
LIFELINE PROGRAM- MOTIONS TO
PASS FOR THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR
TO MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES AND
ADD CO AUTHORS WERE GONNA DO A
ROLL CALL VOTE ON SEVENTY FOUR.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
PORTANTINO. AYE. DINO AYE
CENTER BATES SENATOR BRADFORD
BRADFORD ICE CENTER JONES JERRY
JONES NO CENTER KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER ICE CENTER LAYERED
LAYER BY SENATOR MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE A FIVE TO ONE THE BILL
IS OUT FIVE TO ONE MOVING ON AB
ONE TWO THREE PAID FAMILY LEAVE
WEEKLY BENEFIT AMOUNT INTO A
ROLL CALL VOTE THAT MOTIONS TO
PASS THE BILL ONE TWENTY THREE
EMOTIONS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE CENTER BATES
SENATOR BRADFORD. BRADFORD HI
CENTER JONES SENATOR KAMLAGER I
AM A FIVE SENATOR LAYERED
LAYERED I SENATOR MCGUIRE WIRE
BY FIVE TO ZERO THE BILL IS UP
FIVE TWO ZERO. BUT BEYOND AB
FOUR FIVE ZERO PARAMEDIC
DISCIPLINARY REVIEW THE MOTION
IS TO PASS IT WITHOUT OBJECTION
OF SEPT IN THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FORTY FIVE. THAT BILLS
OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO EIGHTY SEVEN
OH ONE WAREHOUSE DISTRIBUTION
CENTERS CENTERS THE MOTION IS
TO PASS WITH A MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES STRIKE THE CAL OSHA
STANDARD AND NARROW SCOPE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION OF
SUBSTANTIVE ROLL CALL FROM AB
FOURTEEN THAT FILLS OUT SEVEN
SIXTY FIVE TWO TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW. AB ONE
THOUSAND THREE WAGE THEFT GRAND
THEFT- THE MOTIONS TO PASS FOR
THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO ALLOW
COMPENSATION TO BE RECOVERED AS
RESTITUTION IN THE SPECIFIED
THE BILL DOES NOT IMPACT
EXISTING CIVIL OR CRIMINAL
ENFORCEMENT. THAT OBJECTION-
SUBSTITUTE IN THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FORTY FIVE SO THAT THOSE
OUT SEVEN ZERO. MOVING ON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON IS AB
FOUR THIRTY DEBT COLLECTION
IDENTITY THEFT- MOTIONS TO PASS
WITHOUT OBJECTION OF SEVENTEEN
THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY
FIVE SETTLES OUT SEVEN TO ZERO.
AB FOUR FOUR SEVEN INCOME TAXES
LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDITS
MOTIONS TO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS
FOR AUTHORED TO REMOVE THE TAX
LEVY AND MAKE TECHNICAL CHANGES
WITHOUT OBJECTION I'M SUB TO
THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY
FIVE. TO EIGHTY FOUR FOUR SEVEN
PASSES SEVENTY ZERO ABSIX OH
TWO IMPACT FEE NEXUS STUDIES
THE MOTIONS TO PASS WITH THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES OR ANY FEE
NEXUS BASED ON SQUARE FOOTAGE.
AND MAKE OTHER TECHNICAL
CHANGES WITHOUT OBJECTION OF
SUBZERO COFFER MAYBE FORTY FIVE
SB SIX OH TO PASS A SEVENTY
ZERO A. B. ELEVEN OH FOUR AIR
AMBULANCE SERVICE MEDICARE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS EMOTIONS
DO PASS THAT OBJECTION
SUBSTANTIVE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB FORTY FIVE SO AB ELEVEN OH
FOUR PASSES. SEVEN ZERO. MOVING
ON TO ASSEMBLY HOLD AB TWENTY.
P. OFF THE USE FORCE IS A TO
PASS AND WITHOUT OBJECTION OF
SUBSIDY THE ROLE KAUFER MAYBE
FOURTEEN THAT BILL PASSES FIVE
TO TWO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NOW. AB ONE HUNDRED DRINKING
WATER ENDPOINT DEVICES LEAD CAN
CONTENT BECAUSE TO DO PASSING
WITHOUT OBJECTION- SUBSIDY THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE
SO THAT BILL PASSES SEVEN TWO
ZERO. AB ONE HUNDRED AND FIVE
UPWARD MOBILITY ACT OTHER
AMENDMENTS TO PROMOTE INCREASED
DIVERSITY IN THE ACT AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION I'M
SUBSTITUTING THE MOTION. THE
MOTION OF AB FOURTEEN SO AB ONE
OH FIVE PASSES FIVE TO TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW. AB TWO
TWO NINE USE OF FORCE
INSTRUCTION BUREAU OF SECURITY
AND INVESTIGATIVE SERVICES. THE
CITY PASS AND WITHOUT.
OBJECTION OF SUBSTANCE THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE. SO
TWO TWO NINE PASSES SEVEN TWO
ZERO AB TWO FOUR TWO ONE PUBLIC
UTILITIES IT IS A TO PASS. AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION OF SECTION OF
THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY
FIVE SO AB TWO THOUSAND TO FOUR
TWO PASSES SEVEN ZERO. EIGHTY
NINE FOR A REAL ESTATE
APPRAISER LICENSES AT MOTIONS
TO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS PER
AUTHORED AT A CO AUTHOR. AND
MOVE THE NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENT TO A NEW CODE
SECTION WE'RE GONNA ROLL CALL
VOTE ON NINE FOUR EIGHT. SOME
AGO NINE FORTY EIGHT MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO I
RUTINA I CENTER BATES. BATES BY
SENATOR BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
SENATOR JONES JONES KNOWS
CENTER KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER BY
CENTER LAYERED ALL RIGHT THERE
I SENATOR MCGUIRE. ACQUIRE. HI
FOUR SIX TO ONE. ONCE. OKAY SO
THAT WAS NINE FOUR EIGHT PASSES
SIX TO ONE AB TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN ON CALIFORNIA
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT BANK PUBLIC AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT FACILITIES
THIS IS A DO PASS AND I'M
SUBSTITUTING THE MOTION OF AB
FORTY FIVE WITHOUT OBJECTION TO
THE BILL PASSES SEVEN. TWO
ZERO. V. ONTO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
IRWIN AB FOUR EIGHT EIGHT
CHARITABLE FUNDRAISING
PLATFORMS AND PLATFORM
CHARITIES IT IS EIGHT TO PASS
WITH THE MEMBERS PER AUTHORED A
CHANGE. I CONSENT PROVISION
WITHOUT OBJECTION OF SEVENTEEN
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FOURTEEN.
SO AB FOUR EIGHT EIGHT PASSES
FIVE TO TWO WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NOW AB. THREE THREE ONE
THREE THREE ONE ON MENTAL
HEALTH STATEWIDE DIRECTOR
CRISIS SERVICES IT IS A TO PASS
WITHIN A TAKE A ROLL CALL ON
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO I CENTER BATES.
BATES AYE CENTER BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE CENTER JONES EACH
CENTER KAMLAGER I'D LAYERED ALL
LARRY HI AND CENTER MCGUIRE
ACQUIRE A SIXTY ZERO THE BILL
PASSES SIXTIES. THEM ONTO
REGINALD JONES SAWYER. AB EIGHT
OFFICERS MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS
EMOTIONS DO PASS FOR THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO LIMITS
BILLS. POST CERTIFIED OFFICERS
GIVE POST DISCRETION TO AWARD
ALLOWANCES FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
PAST DISCIPLINARY ACTION AND TO
ADD A COURSE. WITHOUT OBJECTION
OF SUBSTANCE THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FORTY FIVE SO AB EIGHT
EIGHTY NINE PASSES SEVEN TWO
ZERO AB FOR A THREE PIECE
OFFICERS OFFICE OF EXPOSITION
PARK MANAGEMENT. MOTIONS TO
PASS WITH AMENDMENTS TO MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES WE'RE GOING
TO DO A ROLL CALL VOTE ON FORTY
THREE. AND THE BILL FOR EIGHTY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
SENATOR PORTANTINO. AYE
PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES
SENATOR BRADFORD ADVERTISED
JONES JONES HI SENATOR KAMLAGER
HI KAMLAGER ICE AND EARLIER
LAYER HI CENTER REQUIRE WIRE I
PUT A SIX TO ZERO THERE WAS OUT
SIX ZERO. AB FIVE NINE NINE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS WILLIAM
SETTLEMENT- THE MOTIONS TO PASS
AND- SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SO THAT BILL PASSES
SEVEN TWO ZERO. AB SEVEN FIFTY
ON PERJURY IS A DO PASSED
MOTION THAT OBJECTION OF
SUBSTANCE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
FORTY FIVE SO AB SEVEN FIFTY
PASSES SEVEN ZERO. AB EIGHT
FIVE EIGHT EMPLOYMENT HEALTH
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY CLINICAL
PRACTICE GUIDELINES IS A DO
PASS WITHOUT OBJECTION OF
SEVENTEEN ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
FOURTEEN TO THAT BILL PASSES
FIVE TO TWO WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. AB THIRTEEN FORTY
SEVEN UNVEILED PREMIUMS IT IS
IF YOU PASS THE OBJECTION OF
SUB TO THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
FORTY FIVE SO THAT BILL PASSES
SEVEN ZERO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA HAS AB TWO NINE THREE-
WHICH IS A DO PASS WITHOUT
OBJECTION I'M SUBSTANTIVE THE
ROLL CALL. FROM AB FORTY FIVE
SO THAT BILL PASSES SEVEN TWO
ZERO AB FOUR SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA
DEFORESTATION SRI. CARE ACT.
WITH IT SAID TO PASS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUBSTANCE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB FOURTEEN TO THE
BILL PASSES FIVE TO TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW. AB
FIFTEEN OH SIX ON WORKER STATUS
EMPLOYEES AND INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS NEWSPAPER
DISTRIBUTION AND CARRIERS. THE
MOTIONS TO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS
PER AUTHORED TO MODIFY
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUBJECT IN THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE. INTO
THAT BILL PASSES SEVEN ZERO.
MOVING ON TO SENATOR TOM
LOGGERS ASSEMBLY BILLS WE HAVE.
A. B. ONE ONE EIGHT WHICH IS A
ROLL CALL VOTE AND IT IS A
MOTION WITH AMENDMENTS PER
AUTHOR TO MAKE THE PROGRAM
CONTINGENT UPON A PUBLIC
APOLOGY APPROPRIATIONS AND MOVE
THE MINISTRATION. OF THE
PROGRAM TO D. S. S. ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE EIGHT THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE CENTER BATES
SENATOR BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
CENTER JONES JONES FIVE CENTER
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER EYES AND
LAYERED BY SENATOR MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE FIVE OF SIX TO ZERO AND
FILLS OUT SIXTY ZERO AB ONE TWO
FOUR ON SYNCING WITH THE MOTION
IS TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS TO
STRIKE THE CONSECUTIVE
SENTENCES AND ENHANCEMENT
PROVISIONS. EXCLUDING VIOLENT
FELONIES AND ALLOW LONGER TERMS
IF AGGRAVATING CIRCUMSTANCES
OUTWEIGH MITIGATING
CIRCUMSTANCES I'M SUB WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUBSTANCE IN THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE FOURTEEN TO THE
BILL WAS APPROVED ON A FIVE TO
VOTE WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NOW. AB. THAT OBJECTION OF
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FOURTEEN SO AB THREE
THREE THREE PASSES FIVE TO TWO
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW AB
THREE SIX NINE MEDIC CAL
SERVICE PERSONS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. IT IS A ROLL CALL
VOTE ON THE MOTION IS TO PASS A
BILL THREE SIXTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE CENTER BATES
SENATOR BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE
SENATOR JONES SENATOR KAMLAGER
HEY KAMLAGER EYES CENTER
LAYERED HI THERE I CENTER
MCGUIRE WHERE ARE FIVE TO ZERO
THE BILLS OUT FIVE ZERO AB NINE
SIX TWO REUSABLE BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS IT IS A DEEP PASS
WITHOUT OBJECTION I'M SUCKING
THE ROLL CALL FOR AB EIGHT
FORTY FIVE SO AB NINE SIX TWO
PASSES SEVENTY ZERO MOVING ON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE AB EIGHT
NINE EIGHT AUTOMATIC CONVICTION
RECORD RELIEF IT IS A DO PASS.
THAT OBJECTION I'M SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB FORTY
FIVE THAT BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO
AB TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT
SUPERVISED PERSONS RELEASED
MOTIONS TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS
TO ALLOW THE COURT TO PRESUME%
THE TRUTH OF THE ALLEGED
VIOLATION AND TO REQUIRE THE
REASONS FOR THE FINDINGS TO BE
ON THE RECORD. AND THEN THE
MINUTES INSTEAD OF IN WRITING-
WITHOUT OBJECTION I'M SENT TO
THE ROLL CALL OF AB FOURTEEN SO
AB TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT IS OUT
FIVE TO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NO AB THIRTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
TRANSIT. DISTRICT POLICE
RESPONSIBILITIES A IS TO PAY
WITH PER AUTHORED LIMIT BILL
TO. WITH THAT OF SUBSTANCE ROLL
CALL FROM AB FORTY FIVE SO THAT
BILL IS OUT SEVEN. ZERO BEYOND
TO LEVINE AB EIGHT TWENTY FIVE
DATA BREACH GENETIC INFORMATION
ROLL CALL THAT IS A TO PASS AND
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A ROLL CALL.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT TWENTY FIVE
MOTIONS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO. AYE
PORTANTINO AYE CENTER BATES
VOIGTS NOT BATES NOW SENATOR
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE SENATOR
JONES JONES KNOWS CENTER
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER EYES CENTER
LAYER ALL RIGHT- EARLIER I
CENTER MCGUIRE CHOIR BUT IT'S
FIVE TWO TWO BILLS OUT FIVE TO
AB EIGHT TWENTY NINE FOSTER
CHILDREN IMMIGRATION COUNSELING
GUARDIANSHIP IS A DEEP PASS AND
WE'RE GONNA DO A ROLL CALL VOTE
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT TWENTY NINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO
HI PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES
CENTER BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
SENATOR JONES. JONES FIVE
CENTER KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER HI
CENTER LAYER ON LAYER BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE WIRA SIX TO
ZERO BILLS OUT SIX ZERO MOVING
ON THAT AB EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDERS IT IS A MOTION WITH
AMENDMENTS PER AUTHORED TO
ALLOW THE PETITIONER TO RECEIVE
DOCUMENTS ELECTRONICALLY OR BY
MAIL AND AMENDMENTS TO MAKE THE
ELECTRIC RUN LIKE TRONIC
FINALLY CONTINGENT UPON
FUNDING. THAT OBJECTION WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE REMOTE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE SO AB
EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN IS OUT SEVEN
TWO ZERO AB EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT
MOBILE SLAUGHTER OPERATIONS
MOTION IS TO PASS WITH THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHORED AT A
REGISTRATION FEE AND LICENSING
FEE MODIFY RECORDKEEPING
REQUIREMENTS AND MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES. THAT
OBJECTION OF SUBSTANCE ROLL
CALL FROM AB FORTY FIVE SO AB
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT IS OUT SEVEN
TO ZERO AB NINE SIX FIVE
BUILDING STANDARDS ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
WE'RE TAKING A ROLL CALL VOTE
ON A DO PASSED MOTION. ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE SIXTY FIVE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
SENATOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE CENTER BATES
BATES KNOWS BRADFORD BRADFORD
AYE SENATOR JONES. JONES I
CENTER KAMLAGER I KAMLAGER I
CENTER LAYERED ON LATER I
CENTER MCGUIRE MCGUIRE FIVE SIX
TO ONE. THE BILL WAS OUT SIXTY
ONE MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW YOUR PMR WITH FOR A
GOOD I'M GOOD HOW TO DISASTER
JONES SINGLE PUBLIC NINE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW AS AB FOUR
SEVEN ONE ZERO OF AUTOMATIC
REPAIR AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR
CITATIONS IN VEHICLE SAFETY
SYSTEMS INSPECTIONS IT IS A DO
PASS WITHOUT OBJECTION I'M SUB
SUB- I'M SUBSTITUTING THE
MOTION FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE
THAT BILL IS OUT SEVEN TWO
ZERO. AB SEVENTY THREE FAR IN
DRIVER'S LICENSE DRIVING TESTS
THAT IS A MOTION WITH THE
MEMBERS TO ADD A PRINCIPAL CO
AUTHOR THAT OBJECTION-
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FOURTEEN TO THAT BILL IS
OUT FIVE TWO WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING. NO AB TEN EIGHTY FOUR
RETAIL DEPARTMENT GENDER
NEUTRAL SECTIONS THIS IS A TO
PASS HIM WITHOUT OBJECTION I'M
SUBSTANTIVE ROLE COOPER MAYBE
FOURTEEN TO THAT BILLS OUT FIVE
TO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO
AB ELEVEN NINETY FOUR
CONSERVATORSHIP MOTIONS TO PASS
WITH A MEMBERS PER AUTHORED A
CHANGE A LICENSING SANCTION
PROVISIONS IMPOSE KIND OF.
CONFIDENTIALITY REQUIREMENTS
AND MAKE OTHER CHANGES ALSO
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE SPECIFIED
PROVISIONS CONTINGENT UPON
FUNDING THE I'M GONNA SUBSIDIZE
THE MOTION FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE
SO THAT BILL WAS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF SEVEN TO ZERO
BASED ON AB FORTY FIVE. MOVING
ON TV FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO BOARD
OF REGISTERED NURSING IT IS A
TO PASS. WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE
SO THAT BILL PASSES SEVENTY
ZERO WITHOUT. OBJECTION AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE ON THE
BOARD OF PHARMACY THE MOTION IS
TO PASS WITH THE MEMBERS TO
MODIFY THE FINE STRUCTURE GOING
TO TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE ON A.
B. FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN THIRTY
pTHREE THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
CENTER PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE CENTER BATES
SENATOR BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE
SENATOR JONES JONES CENTER
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER EYES
CENTER LAYERED LAYERED ICE
CENTER MCGUIRE FIRE HI IT'S
FIVE TO ZERO THE BILLS OUT FIVE
TO ZERO AB FIFTEEN THIRTY FOUR
PORT OF OPTOMETRY- NO
AMENDMENTS AND SO TO DO PASS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUBJECT
AEROCAR FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE SO
THAT BILL PASSES SEVEN TO ZERO
AB FIFTEEN THIRTY FIVE AND
EVERY MEDICAL BOARDS MOTIONS TO
PASS FOR THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR
TO MODIFY THE DEFINITION OF A
SHELTER AND OTHER SPECIFIED
REGISTRATION REQUIREMENTS. THAT
OBJECTION OF SUBSTANCE THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE SAID
PHYLLIS OUT SEVEN ZERO. BNP
COMMITTEE BILL AB FIFTEEN
THIRTY SIX PORT OF OCCASIONAL
NURSING AND PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS MOTIONS TO PASS
WITH THE MEMBERS PER AUTHORED A
MODIFIER SCHOOL APPROVAL FEES
AND MAKE OTHER TACTICAL
CLARIFYING CHANGES. THAT
OBJECTION OF STEPS TO THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE SO.
AB FIFTEEN THIRTY SIX IS OUT
SEVEN TWO ZERO LIVING ON TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN. AB
THREE OH FIVE VETERANS SERVICE
NOTICE. MOTIONS TO PASS FOR THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR REMOVE EDT
FROM THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
BILL WITHOUT OBJECTION. I AM
SUBSTANTIVE ROPE OFFER MAYBE
FORTY FIVE SO AB THREE OH FIVE
PASSES SEVEN TO ZERO. AB FIVE
FIVE SIX MISUSE OF SPERM OVER
AND EMBRYOS IT IS A DO PASS
WITHOUT OBJECTION OF SUBSTANCE
THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY
FIVE. THE BILL PASSES. SEVEN
ZERO EIGHTY FIVE SEVEN SIX
COMMITTEE COLLEGE APPORTIONMENT
FOR COLLEGE COURSES TAUGHT ON
MILITARY BASES. TO DO PASS
MOTION WITHOUT OBJECTION OF
SECTION ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
FORTY FIVE. INTO AB FIVE SEVEN
SIX PASSES SEVEN TWO ZERO.
MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAYES AB THREE NINETY SEVEN
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS
DISQUALIFICATION NOTICE.
MOTIONS TO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS
PER AUTHORED AT A CO AUTHOR
WITHOUT OBJECTION OF SEVENTEEN
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE.
MAYBE THREE NINE SEVEN PASSES
SEVEN TWO ZERO AB FOUR FOUR SIX
ELECTIONS. POLITICAL PARTY
QUALIFICATIONS TO MOTIONS TO
PASS WITH A MEMBERS PER AUTHOR
TO ADDRESS CHAPTER IN ISSUES
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A ROLL CALL
VOTE ON FOUR FOUR SIX ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR FORTY SIX THE MOTIONS
TO PASS AS. AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO
I PORTANTINO EYES AND BATES
SEVEN BRADFORD BRADFORD ICE
JONES I'VE JONES BY SENATOR
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I SAID
EARLIER PLAYWRIGHTS AND I FIRE
BY VOTERS SIX TO ZERO SORT OF
SIX ZERO ROAMING ON THE MCCARTY
AB FOUR SEVENTEEN RISING
SCHOOLS SCHOLARS NETWORK
JUSTICE INVOLVED STUDENTS
MOTIONS TO PASS THAT OBJECTION
I'M SUBS IN THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FORTY FIVE SO AB FOUR
SEVENTEEN PASSES SEVEN TWO ZERO
A. B. SEVEN FIVE NINE ELECTIONS
COUNTY OFFICERS SAID TO PASS
WITHOUT OBJECTION I'M
SUBSTITUTING THE MOTION FROM
FOR THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
FOURTEEN TO THAT BILL PASSES
FIVE TWO TWO. BUT REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO AB SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN
STATE PROPERTY TRANSFER- THE
MOTIONS TO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS
FOR AUTHORED ADDED STIPULATIONS
FOR WHEN A PROJECT ON THE
PROPERTY REQUIRES THE USE OF A
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
DURING A ROLL CALL VOTE ON
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN THE MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO
HI DINO AYE CENTER BATES I KNOW
BATES MOUSE CENTER BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE CENTER JONES.
JONES I CENTER KAMLAGER HI
KAMLAGER I SAID EARLIER ON
PLAYER DIçN CENTER OVER PIRAI
THIRTY SIX TO ONE THE BILL IS
OUT SIX TO ONE AB ELEVEN NINETY
ONE ON FIREARMS MOTIONS TO PASS
FOR THE MEMBERS PER AUTHORED TO
REQUIRE THE REPORTING OF
CERTAIN DATA ROLL CALL VOTE.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN NINETY ONE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
SENATOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES.
BATES AYE SENATOR BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE SENATOR JONES
JONES I CENTER KAMLAGER HI
KAMLAGER I CENTER LAYERED LATER
I SENT HIM A BAHRI VOTERS SEVEN
ZERO THIRTY OUT OF THE BILL'S
SEVEN TWO ZERO V. ON AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX REAL
PROPERTY DISCRIMINATORY
RESTRICTIONS TO MOTIONS TO PASS
FOR THE MEMBERS FOR AUTHORED TO
REPLACE THE TASK FORCE WITH THE
COUNTY RECORDER'S IMPLEMENTING
THEIR OWN SEARCH AND REDUCTION
PROGRAMS AND MAKE RELATED
CHANGES WITHOUT OBJECTION I'M
SUBSTANTIVE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
FORTY FIVE. AND SO AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY SIX WILL PAST SEVEN TO
ZERO AB FIFTEEN FORTY TWO
COUNTY OF YELLOW SECURED
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT PROGRAMS
MOTIONS TO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS
PER AUTHOR TO APPLY TREATMENT
FACILITY TO BE CLINICAL SETTING
PROHIBITED THE FACILITY FROM
BEING IN A CORRECTIONAL SETTING
AND MAKE TECHNICAL CHANGES IT'S
ALL CALL VOTE ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN FORTY TO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO.
AYE PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR
BATES SENATOR BRADFORD BRADFORD
AYE SENATOR JONES JONES I
CENTER KAMLAGER KAMLAGER ICE
CENTER LAYERED HI LARRY I
CENTER MCGUIRE. BUYER I HAVE
SIX TO ZERO FILLS OUT SIX ZERO
MOVING ONTO MEDINA AB ONE OH
ONE HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS ETHNIC STUDIES
MOTIONS TO PASS WITH THE
MEMBERS TO REMOVE THE CHARTER
SCHOOL GRADUATION REQUIREMENT
MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES FOR THE
ETHNIC STUDIES COURSE. AND
INTENT LANGUAGE SPECIFYING THAT
ELEAZAR NOT YOU STRESS
CURRICULUM I WAS NOT ADOPTED
AND AT THE UNIFORMED COMPLAINT
PROCEDURES PROCESS. WITHOUT
OBJECTION I'M SEARCHING THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FOURTEEN
THAT BILLS APPROVED ON A FIVE
TO VOTE WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NO. AB THREE SEVENTY FIVE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PART TIME
FACULTY IS A DO PASS. MOTION
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION OF
SEVENTEEN ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
FORTY FIVE SO AB THREE SEVEN
FIVE PASSES SEVEN ZERO. THREE
NINE TWO SEVEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE BACCALAUREATE DEGREE
PROGRAM- THE MOTIONS TO PASS
WITH AMENDMENTS PER AUTHORED A
SPECIFIED. ISSUES NEEDED FOR
FORMAL OBJECTIONS AND MAKE
OTHER CLARIFYING CHANGES
WITHOUT OBJECTION. I'M SUB TO
THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY
FIVE SO THAT BILL PASSES SEVEN
ZERO. AB ONE ONE ONE THREE POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION TUITION AND
FEE WAIVERS MOTIONS TO PASS
WITH THE MEMBERS PER AUTHORED
BY CHAPTER RING TO BALLBOY
CHATTERING ISSUES AND MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES. THAT
OBJECTION OF SUBS IN THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE SO
THAT BILL PASSES SEVEN TO ZERO.
A. B. FOURTEEN FIFTY SIXTEEN
FINANCIAL AID CAL GRANT REFORMS
MOTIONS TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS
TO MAKE THE PROGRAM CONTINGENT
UPON APPROPRIATIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION INCEPTION THE ROPE
OFFER MAYBE FORTY FIVE SEVERAL
PASSES SEVEN ZERO IF. WE ARE TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI AB
FIVE ELEVEN SECURITIES
TRANSACTIONS QUALIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS MOTIONS TO PASS
WITHOUT OBJECTION I'M
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB. FORTY FIVE SEVERAL PASSES
SEVEN ZERO AB. FIVE FIVE SEVEN
HATE CRIMES MOTIONS TO PASS A
THE PER AUTHOR TO MAKE THE FE
D. ADMINISTER APAR AND MAY TO
MAKE THE PROGRAM CONTENT UPON
ROLL CALL THE FIVE SEVEN.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FIFTY SEVEN
THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
PORTANTINO. AYE PORTANTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES. ABILITY CENTER
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE SENATOR
JONES SENATOR KAMLAGER KAMLAGER
I CENTER LAYERED LAYERED ICE
CENTER MCGUIRE CHOIR HI FIVE
ZERO THE BILLS OUT FIVE ZERO
MOVING ON TO AB THIRTEEN NINETY
FIVE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE CRISIS
ACT THE MOTION IS TO PASS WITH
THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES MAKE OTHER
CHANGES AND ADD CO AUTHORS
WE'RE GOING TO DO A PROCOL VOTE
ON THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE. THE
BILL THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO AYE
CENTER BATES. ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE. BATES NOW
SENATOR BRADFORD SENATOR JONES
JONES KNOWS CENTER KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER EYES LAYERED LAYERED
ICE CENTER REQUIRE WIRE I
VOTERS. FORTY TO FORTY TO
MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NIGERIAN AB FIVE TWO THREE
PROGRAM OF ALL INCLUSIVE CARE
FOR THE ELDERLY MOTIONS TO PASS
WITHOUT OBJECTION OR
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB FORTY FIVE FOR THE BILL IS
OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO. AB SEVEN
FOUR NINE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES MEDICAL DIRECTION
CERTIFICATION MOTIONS TO PASS
WITH THE MEMBERS TO PROVIDE
ALTERNATIVE QUALIFICATIONS FOR
Q. CARE HOSPITALS AND S. N. F.
UNITS WITHOUT OBJECTION OF SUBS
IN THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
FORTY FIVE THE BILL IS OUT
SEVEN. ZERO THERE'S A EDUCATION
COMMITTEE BILL AB FOUR EIGHT
SIX ELEMENTARY AND SECONDARY
EDUCATION SECONDARY EDUCATION
OMNIBUS BILL NO IT'S SAID TO
PASS WITHOUT OBJECTION I'M
SEARCHING THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FORTY FIVE INTO THE BILL
PASSES SEVEN TWO ZERO. LIVING
ON THE PATTERSON AB TWO SIX TWO
HUMAN TRAFFICKING CONVICTION
RELIEF. MOTIONS TO PASS WITH
THE MEMBERS PER AUTHORED THE
STRIKE REQUIREMENTS REQUIRED
DESTRUCTION OF DAC DNA
SPECIMENS ACTION OF SUB TO THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE
AB TWO SIX TWO IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS SEVEN ZERO VOTE AB
THREE SEVENTEEN OFFICE OF
FOSTER CARE ON THE BOOK I'M THE
BEST PERSON. MOTIONS TO PASS
WITHOUT OBJECTION OF SUBSTANCE
THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY
FIVE THREE B. THREE SEVENTEEN
PASSES SEVEN ZERO. MOVING ON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
AB SEVENTY TWO COASTAL
ADAPTATION PROJECTS GREG
REGULATORY REVIEW REPORT.
MOTIONS TO PASS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUBJECT ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FORTY FIVE. AND SO THE
MOTIONS OF THE BILL PASSES
SEVEN TWO ZERO AB ELEVEN SHE
MADE ELEVEN ONE TEN FRAUDULENT
CLAIMS INMATES THE MOTIONS TO
PASS WITHOUT OBJECTION SUBJECT
IN THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
FORTY FIVE THE BILL PASSES
SEVEN TWO ZERO AB TEN FIFTY
SEVEN FIREARMS MOTIONS TO PASS
FOR THE MEMBERS PER AUTHORED TO
DELAY THE OPERATIVE STATE AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION SECTION ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE TO
THE BILL PASSES SEVEN ZERO AB
ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT ALCOHOLISM
OR DRUG ABUSE RECOVERY
TREATMENT FACILITIES MOTIONS TO
PASS WITH THE MEMBERS PER
AUTHORED TO ALLOW ALL NONPROFIT
RECOVERY RESIDENCES FIFTEEN
COVERAGE UNDER THE RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTY POLICY AND TO MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SUBZERO COOPER MAYBE
FORTY FIVE SO AB ELEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT PASSES SEVEN TWO ZERO.
HOLD ON ONE SECOND. I IS
GETTING A TEXT FROM WHAT KASKY
YES MY COUNTY IS WATCHING
EVERYTHING WE'RE DOING YEAH OUR
DATES MCGUIRE WE'RE MOVING ON
TO. QUIRK AB THREE EIGHT SIXTY
ME TOO EIGHT SEVEN CIVIL ACTION
STATURE LIMITATIONS AND IS A DO
PASSED WITHOUT OBJECTION WAS
SUBSTITUTING THE MORAL CALL
FROM AB FORTY FIVE. SO AB TWO
EIGHT SEVEN PASSES SEVEN ZERO
AB FIVE THREE SEVEN WIRELESS
TELECOMMUNICATIONS AND
BROADBAND FACILITIES MOTIONS TO
PASS WITH THE MEMBERS PER
AUTHORED A STRIKE PROVISIONS
RELATED TO BE EXPEDITED
JUDICIAL REVIEW WE'RE GOING TO
WIN A ROLL CALL VOTE. ON FIVE
THREE SEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN THEM MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO NINE
PORTANTINO AYE CENTER BATES
BETTER BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE
SENATOR JONES JONES I CENTER
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER EYES
CENTER LAYERED ALL RIGHT LATER
BY SENATOR MCGUIRE CHOIR FIVE
SIX TWO ZERO DOUBLES OUT SIXTY
ZERO MOVING ON A. B. SEVEN OH
SEVEN MERCURY THERMOSTAT
COLLECTION ACTIVE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. IT IS A MOTION WITH THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHORED TO REQUIRE
MANUFACTURERS TO MAKE CERTAIN
PAYMENTS AND MAKE OTHER CHANGES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUBJECT IN
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE
FOR THE BILL'S OUT SEVEN TWO
ZERO. AB NINE FIVE FIVE
CALTRANS ENCROACHMENT PERMITS
FOR BROADBAND INSTALLATION THE
MOTIONS DO PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS TO DELETE PROVISIONS
REQUIRING CALTRANS OFFER. TO
ACT AS THE LEAD AGENCY FOR
SEQUEL PURPOSES. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUBJECT IN THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE SO
THAT BILL PASSES SEVEN TWO
ZERO. AB TWELVE NINETY FOUR
COUNTY CHILDREN CHILD CARE
PILOT PROGRAMS. MOTIONS TO PASS
FOR THE MEMBERS TO AUTHORIZE
THE PROGRAM UNTIL JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND REQUIRE
A STUDY WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE MOTION FOR
MAYBE FORTY FIVE. SO TWELVE
NINETY FOUR PASSES SEVEN TWO
ZERO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CORK
SILVA AB SIXTY EIGHT STATE
HOUSING PLAN ANNUAL REPORT
MOTIONS TO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS
PER AUTHOR TO NARROW THE SCOPE
OF THE STATE HOUSING PLAN
REQUIREMENTS AND MAKE TECHNICAL
CHANGES. THAT OBJECTION OF
SUBSTANTIVE THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FORTY FIVE SO AB SIXTY
EIGHT PASSES SEVENTY ZERO. AB
THREE SIX TO HOMELESS SHELTERS
INSPECTIONS MOTIONS TO PASS FOR
THE MEMBERS PER AUTHORED TO
EXCLUDE PROJECT ROOM KEY
SHELTERS FROM INSPECTION
REQUIREMENTS ELIMINATE
MANDATORY. ANNUAL INSPECTION TO
MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES WERE
TAKING A ROLL CALL VOTE ON
THREE SIX TWO. ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE SIXTY TO THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES.
BATES KNOWS SENATOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE SENATOR JONES.
JONES KNOWS SENATOR KAMLAGER.
KAMLAGER I CENTER LAYER. LAYER
BY SENATOR MCGUIRE WHERE I
VOTERS FIVE TWO. BILLS OUT FIVE
TO MOVING ON AB SEVEN NINE ZERO
CONSUMER LEGAL REMEDIES ACT.
THE MOTIONS TO PASS AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUBSTANTIVE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE THE BILL
PASSES SEVEN TWO ZERO. AB EIGHT
SIX FIVE CHILD CARE OF TURNER
PAYMENT PROGRAMS BUT OUT OF-
THE MOTIONS TO PASS WITH THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO AVOID
CHATTERING ISSUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION OF SUB TO THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE. AB
EIGHT SIX FIVE PASSES SEVEN
ZERO V. ON THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS AB TWO TWO SIX CHILDREN'S
CRISIS PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT FACILITIES. WE'RE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS WITH A
MEMBERS PER AUTHORED THE LIMIT
TO ACCREDITED NONPROFITS
ALLOWED DH CS THE LIMIT THAT'S
AND REMOVE LOCKS REQUIREMENTS.
THE ROLL CALL VOTE ON TWO TWO
SIX. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO TWENTY
SIX THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
SENATOR PORTANTINO. HI
PORTANTINO I SENATOR BATES.
BATES AYE SENATOR BRADFORD
ADVERTISEMENT JONES JONES I
CENTER KAMLAGER I'M VOTING
SENATOR LAYERED. LAYER I
SENATOR MCGUIRE MCGUIRE FIVE
SIX TO ZERO AT THE WITHOUT
SIXTY ZERO AB EIGHT SEVEN THREE
CHILD WELFARE SERVICES INDIAN
TRIBES THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND WILL DO A ROLL CALL VOTE
SUBSTITUTION MAYBE WE'RE GONNA
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FORTY FIVE SO AB EIGHT
SEVEN THREE PASSES SEVEN ZERO.
A. B. NINE FOUR FIVE STUDENT
ADORNMENTS OF GRADUATION
CEREMONIES- WE AGES DO PASS
WITHOUT OBJECTION OF SEVENTEEN
ROKOV AB FORTY FIVE SO AB EIGHT
NINE FOUR FIVE PASSES SEVEN
ZERO AB TEN FIFTY FIVE TRAVEL
FOSTER USES A DO PASS WITHOUT
OBJECTION INCEPTION ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE. RETAIN
TEN FIFTY FIVE PASSES SEVEN
ZERO AB ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE
CALIFORNIA DESERT CONSERVATION
PROGRAM IS A DEEP PASS WE'RE
GONNA TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
PORTANTINO. BY. PORTANTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES OKAY CENTER
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE SENATOR
JONES KNOWS CENTER KAMLAGER.
KAMLAGER EYES CENTER LAYERED.
LAYERED I CENTER MCGUIRE.
ACQUIRE BY. IS FIVE TWO ONE.
THE BILL IS OUT. FIVE TO ONE.
ALL RIGHTS WERE MOVING ON TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS AB FOR
TWELVE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
HUMAN RIGHTS MOTION IS TO PASS
FOR THE MEMBERS FOR AUTHORED A
ADDED CHATTERING LANGUAGE AND
CO AUTHORS- WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB FOURTEEN TO THAT BILLS OUT
FIVE TWO WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO AB FOR THIRTY EIGHT
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
LAYOFF NOTICES IN HEARINGS.
MOTIONS TO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS
FOR AUTHOR TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES WITHOUT OBJECTION.
INCEPTION ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
FOURTEEN SO AB FOUR THREE EIGHT
IS OUT FIVE TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW. AB FOUR
SIX NINE STUDENT FINANCIAL AID
APPLICATIONS- THE MOTIONS TO
PASS WITH AMENDMENTS TO ADD A
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUBSTANTIVE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE. THE BILL
IS OUT SEVENTY TWO ZERO. AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM MOTION
TO PASS AND WERE SUBSTITUTING
THE ROCK FOR MAYBE FOURTEENTH
WITHOUT OBJECTION. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY NINE PASSES FIVE TWO
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO
EIGHTY FOURTEEN SIXTY ONE HUMAN
SERVICES NONCITIZENS VICTIMS.
IT IS A MOTION WITH THE MEMBERS
PER AUTHOR TO CLARIFY
POPULATION SCOPE WITHOUT
OBJECTION RECEPTION THE MOTION
FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE. DOUBLE
PASSES SEVENTY ZERO MOVING ONTO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF US AB
TWENTY SEVEN HOUSING
QUESTIONNAIRE FOR HOMELESS
YOUTH. MOTIONS TO PASS FOR THE
MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO MAKE IT
MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES OR
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FORTY EIGHT HE MAY BE
FORTY FIVE CB TWENTY SEVEN
PASSES SEVEN TO ZERO. AB FORTY
SIX CALIFORNIA YOUTH AND DALMAN
ACT EMPOWERMENT ACT. MOTIONS TO
PASS FOR THE MEMBERS PER
AUTHORED A CHAPTER IN LANGUAGE
AND MAKE THIS BILL CONTINGENT
UPON APPROPRIATIONS CAN TAKE A
ROLL CALL IN EIGHTEEN FORTY SIX
ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY SIX THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
PORTANTINO. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES SENATOR BRADFORD
BRADFORD HIS JOE JR NO CENTER I
KAMLAGER EYES CENTER LAYERED HI
CENTER MCGUIRE CHOIR I IT'S
FIVE TO ONE THIRTY FORTY SIX
PASSES FIVE TO ONE MOVIE ON AB
THREE TWENTY SIX HEALTH CARE
SERVICE PLANS CONSUMER
PARTICIPANT PROGRAMS MOTIONS TO
PASS WITHOUT OBJECTION OR
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB FOURTEEN. SO THAT BILL
PASSES FIVE TWO TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO AB EIGHT
FIFTEEN SCHOOL NURSE
CREDENTIALING WHERE THE MOTIONS
TO PASS WITH THE MEMBERS TO
LIMIT THE AUTHORIZATION TO
ELEAZAR WITH ENROLLMENT
EXCEEDING FORTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS. THE MOTION WILL BE
SET WHERE SUBSTANTIVE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE SO THAT
BILLS APPROVED UNANIMOUSLY
SEVEN TWO ZERO. MOVING ON AB
NINE EIGHT FOUR VEHICLE
IDENTIFICATION AND REGISTRATION
ALTERNATIVE DEVICES THE MOTIONS
TO PASS A MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
EXTEND THE OPERATION OF THE
PILOT. BY ONE YEAR IMPOSING
PENALTIES FOR COUNTERFEITING
ELECTRONIC DEVICES AND LIMIT
THE USE OF GPS TRACKING
CAPABILITIES. TAKING A ROLL
CALL ON A. B. NINE EIGHT FOUR.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE EIGHTY FOR
THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
PORTANTINO HI TINA I CENTER
BATES. BATES AYE SENATOR
BRADFORD. BRADFORD BY SENATOR
JONES. JONES BY SENATOR
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER I SAID
EARLIER HI THERE I CENTER
MCGUIRE WHY HI SEVEN IS A SIX
WITHOUT SEVEN ZERO. AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY THREE CHILDCARE DO
LANGUAGE LEARNERS THE MOTION IS
TO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR TO AVOID CHAPTER ISSUES
AND MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES
RECEPTION IN THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FORTY FIVE SO THAT BILLS
APPROVED SEVEN TWO ZERO. AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY HIGHER EDUCATION
LABOR RELATIONS EMPLOYEE
ORGANIZATIONS MOTION IS TO PASS
WITHOUT OBJECTION OR
SUBSTITUTING THE WRONG OFFER
MAYBE FOURTEENTH THAT BILLS OUT
FIVE TO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT
RIVAS HAS AB SEVENTY THREE
EMPLOYMENT SAFETY AGRICULTURE
WORKERS MOTIONS TO PASS WITH
THE MEMBERS PER AUTHORED AT
LEAST THE WILDFIRE SMOKE STRIKE
TEAMS AND MODIFY TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS FOR SUBSTANTIVE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE
SO THAT BILL IS OUT WITHOUT
OBJECTION SEVEN TWO ZERO. AB
TWO FIVE TWO MULTI BENEFIT
LANDRY RE PURPOSING PROGRAMS.
MOTIONS TO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS
PER AUTHORED REQUIRED DO SEE TO
SOLICIT INPUT FROM FARMERS AND
RANCHERS ALLOW. THE MARCH
REQUIREMENT TO BE SUSPENDED TO
MAKE OTHER CHANGES AND ALSO
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE THE LAND
CONVERSION PERMANENT- WE'RE
SUBSTANTIVE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
FORTY FIVE SO THAT BILL IS OUT
SEVEN TO ZERO WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB TWO EIGHT FOUR. CLIMATE GOAL
NATURAL AND. WORKING LANDS TO
MOTIONS DO PASS RECEPCI IN THE
MOST FOR MAY FOURTEENTH SO THAT
BILL WILL PASS FIVE TO TWO
WITHOUT OBJECTION WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW. AB
ELEVEN TEN CLEAN VEHICLE-
DEVOTES PERSON. MOTIONS TO PASS
WITH THE MEMBERS PER AUTHORED
AND LEGISLATIVE FINDINGS AND
DECLARATIONS REMOVE REFERENCES
TO THE OFFICE AND MAKE OTHER
CHANGES IN THE OMNIBUS OMNI
BUDS PERSON'S DUTIES. THAT
OBJECTION INCEPTION THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE SO
THAT BILL IS OUT SEVEN TWO
ZERO. AB SEVEN NINETEEN ON
BEES. MOTIONS TO PASS WITH THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO UPDATE
DEFINITIONS AND MAKE CLARIFYING
ANOTHER CHANGES WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH IN ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FORTY FIVE. FOR THAT BILL
IS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO. QUITE
THE BUZZ AB SEVEN FOR MR
RODRIGUEZ LONTANO THE NUMBER
DOWN ON AB SEVEN EMERGENCY
AMBULANCE EMPLOYEES SUBSIDIZE
PROTECTIVE GEAR TO MOTIONS TO
PASS WITHOUT OBJECTION I'M
SUBSTANTIVE RALPH OFFER MAYBE
FOURTEEN BILLS APPROVED FIVE TO
TWO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW
AB THREE SIX FOR FOREIGN LABOR
CONTRACTOR REGISTRATION IS A DO
PASS WITHOUT OBJECTION
SEVENTEEN ROLE QUALITY B.
FOURTEEN. THAT BILLS OUT FIVE
TWO TWO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NOW AB FIVE EIGHTY EMERGENCY
SERVICES VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
TO DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
MOTION WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
IN THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
FORTY FIVE SAID THAT BILL
PASSES SEVEN ZERO SB SIX
FIFTEEN HIGHER EDUCATION
EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE RELATIONS ACT
MOTIONS TO PASS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUBSTANTIVE ROCK
OFFER MAYBE FOURTEEN. FABI SIX
FIFTEEN PASSES FIVE TWO TWO
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW AB
SEVEN FOUR FOUR S. R. EIGHTY
THREE RELINQUISHMENT MOTIONS TO
PASS AND WITHOUT OBJECTION
RECEPTION ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
FORTY FIVE SEVERAL PASSES SEVEN
ZERO AB FIFTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
CALLOW YES STATE REGISTRY THAT
IS TO DO PASSED WITHOUT
OBJECTION PERCEPTION THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE. FORTY FIVE SO
THAT BILL PASSES SEVEN ZERO.
MOVE ON TO A SO MEMBER WE
HADN'T FROM THE AUDIENCE AB
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT UNLAWFUL
CANNABIS ACTIVITY ENFORCEMENT
IS A DO PASSED WITHOUT
OBJECTIONS WHICH HAVE SEEN THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE.
THAT BILL PASSES SEVEN ZERO AB
TWELVE FORTY THREE PROTECTIVE
ORDER ELDERLY INDEPENDENT
ADULTS MOTIONS TO PASS FOR THE
MEMBERS PER OFFICER REVISED
DEADLINES AND FOR JUDICIAL
COUNCIL FORMS. WITHOUT
OBJECTION RECEPTION ROPE OFFER
MAYBE FORTY FIVE STAFF BILL
PASSES SEVEN TWO ZERO WILL BE
ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS AB
FIFTY SIX BENEFITS CLAIM
PROCESSING REPORTING THE DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION RECEPTION ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE SEVERAL
PASSES SEVEN. ZERO AB SEVENTY
GENE SYNTHESIS PROVIDERS AND
MANUFACTURERS BIOSECURITY
PROTOCOLS MY TO PASS FOR THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR PROVIDE FOR
EARLY COLLECTION OF FEES
BEGINNING JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND IT'S A ROLL CALL
VOTE ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
PORTANTINO. HI PORTANTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES SENATOR BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE SENATOR JONES
SENATOR KAMLAGER I KAMLAGER II
CENTER LAYERED LAYERED ICE
CENTER MCGUIRE WHERE ARE FIVE
TO ZERO NOW FILLS OUT FIVE
ZERO- IN AB ONE OH SEVEN
LICENSURE VETERANS AND MILITARY
SPOUSES MOTIONS TO PASS FOR THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHORED AND CO
AUTHORS AND CLARIFY TIME LINES
IN TERMS OF THE INSURANCE
SHOULD MAKE ISSUANCE. OR
TERMINATION OF TEMPORARY
LICENSES WITHOUT OBJECTION
RECEPTION THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FORTY FIVE THE BILL
PASSES SEVEN TWO ZERO AB TEN
AGENCY STREETS AND HIGHWAYS
RECYCLED MATERIALS IT IS A TO
PASS HIM WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE'RE SUBSTANTIVE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FORTY FIVES THAT BILL
PASSES. SEVEN ZERO. BUILDING ON
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO A.
B. FOUR FIVE SEVEN PROTECTION
OF HE HAD HE ME PATIENT CHOICE
IN TELE HEALTH PROVIDER ACT. IT
IS A DO PASS MOTION WITHOUT
OBJECTION RECEPTION ROGOFF
MAYBE FOURTEEN SAY BEFORE FIVE
SEVEN PASSES FIVE TO TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW. AB FIVE
SEVENTY DEPENDENT PARENT HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE MOTIONS TO PASS
FOR THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
DELETE DENTAL INSURANCE AND
MAKE TECHNICAL CHANGES TO
NOTICE REQUIREMENTS. RECEPTION
THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
FOURTEEN SEVERAL PASSES FIVE TO
TWO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW
AB NINE NINE ZERO. IN MAKING
VISITATION WITH ITS EMOTION
WITH THE MEMBERS FOR AUTHORED
TO EXEMPT IN PERSON VISITS IN
CERTAIN JAILS LIMIT THE
PROHIBITION ON. DENYING IN
PERSON CONTACT VISITS THE CDC
ARE AND REQUIRE CDC ARE TO
PROVIDE A REASON FOR REJECTING
A VISITOR TO ROLL CALL VOTE ON
NINE NINE ZERO. AB NINE NINETY
THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
PORTANTINO AYE. PORTANTINO AYE
CENTER BATES PAGE NO SENATOR
BRADFORD BRADFORD I CENTER I'VE
JONES ICE KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER
EYES CENTER LAYERED I SENATE
MCGUIRE WHY. SIX TO ONE THE
BILL IS OUT. SIX TO ONE. AND
WE'RE MOVING ON AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY SEVEN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
BANKING ACT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS FOR THE MEMBERS PER
AUTHORED TO RENAME THE PROGRAM
AND ESTABLISH THE CALICO-
RIBBON COMMISSION TO CONDUCT.
MARKET ANALYSIS THE MOTION IS
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL
CALL FROM MAYBE FOURTEEN SO
THAT BILL WILL PASS FIVE TO TWO
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW. AB
TWO SIXTY STONE OUR MOVING ON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SEVENTY TWO
SIXTY THE MOTIONS TO PASS WITH
THE MEMBERS PER OFTEN TO MAKE
THE EXPANSION OF FOSTER CARE
SUBSIDIES CONTINGENT ON
FUNDING. AND TO REQUIRE THE
DEVELOPMENT AND DISTRIBUTION OF
A SPECIFIED FORM SUBJUGATING
THE ROLL CALL OF AB FORTY FIVE
THE BILL PASSES SEVEN TO ZERO
AB TWO NINE TWO PRISON CREDITS
TO MOTIONS TO PASS FOR THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR. TO LIMIT
THE BILL TO THE REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAM PROVISION WE'RE SUB TO
THE ROCK OFFER MAYBE FOURTEEN
A. B. C. NINETY PASSES FIVE TO
TWO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO
AB THREE FIFTEEN VOLUNTARY
STREAM RESTORATION PROJECTS.
MOTIONS TO PASS WITH A MEMBERS
PROFIT REQUIRE CERTAIN CIVIL
LIABILITY COSTS BE PAID FROM
THE GENERAL FUND AND MAKE OTHER
CHANGES WERE SUB TO THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE. STEP
BILL PASSES SEVENTY ZERO AB
FOUR TO FOUR PRIVATE STUDENT
LOAN COLLECTIONS REFORM ACT
MOTIONS TO PASS WITH A MEMBERS
PER AUTHORED AND CO AUTHORED.
TO ADD A CO AUTHOR EXEMPTIONS
AND DELAY IMPLEMENTATION OR
SUBSTITUTING THE MOTION OF AB
FOURTEEN THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FOURTEEN TO THE BILL
PASSES FIVE TO TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW. AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY SIX SUPERIOR
COURT LACTATION ROOMS IT IS A
DO. PASS. MOTION THE DEEPER
MOTION SIR WORKSHOPS THE ROLL
CALL FROM A. B. I THOUGHT. ALL
RIGHT THIS IS A DO PASS AND AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY SEVENTY SIX OR
SUBS IN THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
FORTY FIVE THAT BILL IS
APPROVED UNANIMOUSLY SEVEN
ZERO. MOVING ON TO MR TANG AB
THIRTY THREE ENERGY
CONSERVATION ASSISTANCE ACT
EXPANDED ELIGIBILITY- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS A MORE
SUBSTANTIVE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
FORTY FIVE SO AB THIRTY THREE
PASSES SEVEN ZERO. AB FIVE SIX
ONE HELP HOMEOWNERS ADD NEW
HOUSING PROGRAMS EIGHTY YOU
FINANCING MOTIONS TO PASS WITH
THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
STRIKE NEW PROGRAMS AND INSTEAD
REQUIRE THE SDO. TO CONDUCT A
STUDY ON ESTABLISHING AN EIGHTY
YOU FINANCING PROGRAM THE
MOTION PERCEPTION OF ROLL CALL
VOTE WHICH ME RECEPTION THE
VOTE FOR MAYBE FOURTEEN TO THAT
BILL PASSES FIVE TWO TWO. WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO AB TWELVE
ALL ONE COMPOSED ABILITY AND
BIODEGRADE ABILITIES LABELING.
MOTIONS TO PASS WITH A MEMBERS
TO CLARIFY AFFECTED PRODUCTS
AND MAKE OTHER CHANGES WERE
DURING A ROLL CALL VOTE ON
TWELVE OH ONE. AM THE BILL
TWELVE A ONE THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE CENTER BATES
SENATOR BRADFORD. BRADFORD ICE
CENTERS JONES. JONES BY SENATOR
KAMLAGER THANK. THE MOTOR FIVE
SENATORS LAYERED LAYERED I
CENTER MCGUIRE WHERE ARE THOSE.
SIX TO ZERO FOUR SIX ZERO SEVEN
WAS OUT MOVING ON AB TWELVE
THIRTY EIGHT J. WALKING I'M
WALKING HERE- WALKING HERE WHO
KNOWS WHAT MOVIE THAT'S FROM
NOW- MIDNIGHT COWBOY I'M
LOOKING HERE I'M WORKING I'VE
BEEN WAITING TO SAY THAT AB
TWELVE THIRTY. THESE THINGS
THAT I DON'T KNOW THEY'RE BOTH
PRETTY GOOD FOR. MORE
CONVENIENT AB TWELVE THIRTY
EIGHT JAY WALKING VIOLATIONS-
THE MOTION IS TO PASS A TO
BREAK IT UP AT SOME POINT WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FOURTEEN TO THAT BILL
PASSES FIVE TO TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW.AB
FIFTEEN FORTY CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE SENTENCING THE
MOTIONS TO PASS WITH THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHORED TO REVISE
THE INTENT LANGUAGE AND TO MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES. WERE SUB TO
THE ROCK OFFER MAYBE FOURTEEN
SO AB FIFTEEN FORTY PASSES FIVE
TO TWO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NOW HOLD ON ONE SECOND. ALL
RIGHT MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VALLADARES AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ADDRESS
CONFIDENTIALITY IS A DO PASS
RECEPTION THE MOTION FOR MAYBE
FORTY FIVE THE BILL PASSES
SEVEN TO ZERO AB FOUR EIGHTEEN
EMERGENCY SERVICE GRANT PROGRAM
WERE SUBSTITUTING IT'S A DO
PASS FOR SUBSTANTIVE IN THE
VOTE FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE SO
THAT BILL PASSES SEVEN TWO
ZERO. THE THING ON TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VIA- THE- THE MOTION
SHIMMY AB THREE FIVE ZERO ON
CANNELLA ENVIRONMENTAL FARMING
ACT OF NINETEEN NINETY FIVE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE GRANT
PROGRAM MOTIONS TO PASS WITH
THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
CLARIFY GRANT PROGRAMMER CRIME
IT'S AN UPDATED DEFINITION
SUBSIDY THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
FORTY FIVE THAT BILL PASSES
SEVEN TWO ZERO. AB THREE NINE
ONE POLLINATOR HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUNDING MOTIONS TO
PASS FOR THE MEMBERS PER
OFFERED TO MAKE A CLARIFYING
CHANGE PERCEPTION THE MOTION
FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE SEVERAL
PASSES SEVENTY ZERO AB FOUR SIX
ONE CAL. WORKS WELL FOR TO WORK
SELF EMPLOYMENT TO DO PASS
MOTION WE'RE SUBSTANTIVE COOPER
FORTY FIVE THAT BILL WAS
APPROVED UNANIMOUSLY SEVEN
ZERO. MOVING ONTO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ASSEMBLY- MINORITY
LEADER WALDRON AB SIX FIVE
THREE MEDICATION ASSISTED
TREATMENT GRANT PROGRAMS THE
MOTION IS TO PASS FOR THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHORED ALLOW
PEACE BE SEC TO RECOVER ITS
COSTS FROM THE GRANT FUNDS.
MOTIONS TWO THIRDS TO PASS
WITHOUT A MEMORY AND SO WE'RE
SUBSTANTIVE ROLE THE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE THAT BILL
PASSES SEVEN ZERO. A. B. SIX
NINE TWO LAKE WALFORD GRANT
FUNDING LIQUIDATION. IT IS A DO
PASS WTHOUT OBJECTION
RECEPTION THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FORTY FIVE SO THAT BILL
PASSES SEVEN ZERO. AB TEN
EIGHTY TWO CALIFORNIA HEALTH
BENEFITS REVIEW PROGRAM
EXTENSIONS MOTIONS TO PASS
WITHOUT OBJECTION RECEPTION
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE
DOUBLE PASSES. SEVEN ZERO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD EIGHTY TWO
EIGHTEEN CHANGE OF GENDER AND
SEX IDENTIFIER. MOTIONS TO PASS
WITH THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
MAKE CONFORMING CHANGES TO FEE
PROVISIONS SUBZERO COFFER MAYBE
FOURTEEN SEVERAL PASSES FIVE TO
TWO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NOW. AB TWO TO THREE DEADLY
ATTACKS TAKING AND POSSESSION.
TO DO PASSED WITHOUT OBJECTION
RECEPTION ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
FORTY FIVE STEP BILL PASSES
SEVEN ZERO. AB THREE FORTY
GOLDEN STATE SCHOLARSHIP.
SCHOLARSHIP OR TRUST IT IS A
DEEP PASS OBJECTION WAS
SUBSTANTIVE CALL FROM FORTY
FIVE THE BILL PASSED SEVEN
ZERO. AB ONE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CAREER IN COLLEGE FOR COURSES
IT IS A DO PASS RECEPTION ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY FIVE SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION A BILL PASSES
SEVEN ZERO. AB FIVE HUNDRED
COASTAL DEVELOPMENT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS A DO PASS. WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FOURTEEN SO THAT BILL IS
APPROVED FIVE TO TWO WITH-REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW. EIGHTY
FIVE FOURTEEN DISTRIBUTION OF
SEXUALLY EXPLICIT MATERIALS IT
IS A DEEP PASS FOR SEVENTEEN
THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE FORTY
FIVE SET UP THOSE APPROVED
UNANIMOUSLY SEVEN ZERO. MOVING
ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHOEVER
AB TWELVE OH SEVEN PATHWAY TO
PANDEMIC TASK FORCE TO DO PASS
RECEPTIONS IN THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FORTY FIVE THAT BILL
PASSES SEVEN ZERO. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS A BEFORE- TO
OFFICER OFFICE OF CLIMATE
ADVOCATE MOTIONS TO PASS WITH
THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES AND CAP THE
SIZE OF THE OFFICE RECEPTION
ROLL CALL. MAYBE FORTY FIVE
THAT BILLS APPROVED SEVEN TO
ZERO A. B. TEN FORTY ONE
EMPLOYMENT LEAVE IS A DO PASS.
RECEPTION TO THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FOURTEEN TO THAT BILL
PASSES FIVE TWO TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW. AB
TWELVE R. FOR HOSPITAL EQUITY
REPORTED MOTIONS TO PASS WITH
THE MAY TO RE CON WITH CA
EQUITY REQUIREMENTS RECEPCI
ROKAHR FROM AB FOURTEEN SEVERAL
PASSES FIVE TO TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW. AB
FORTINO FIVE FAIR DEBT
SETTLEMENT PRACTICES ACT. IT IS
A DO PASS AND RECEPTION THE
ROLE KAUFER MAYBE FOURTEEN TO
THE BILL PASSES FIVE TO TWO
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW.
EIGHTY FOURTEEN FIFTY FIVE
SEXUAL ASSAULT BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS STATURE
LIMITATIONS. THIS IS A NEW
PASSWORD DURING A ROLL CALL.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN FIFTY
FIVE MOTIONS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO HI.
TINA I CENTER BATES SENATOR
BRADFORD. ARE BRADFORD AYE
SENATOR JONES CENTER KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER I SAID EARLIER THERE
BY SENATOR MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
THOSE FIVE TO ZERO THE BILLS
OUT FIVE ZERO MOVING ON TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOODS AB NINE
COMMUNITY WILDFIRE PREPAREDNESS
AND MITIGATION IS A DO PASS THE
THOR SECTION THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE FORTY FIVE THAT FILLS OUT
SEVEN TO ZERO AB FORTY ONE
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE.
MOTIONS TO PASS WITH THE
MEMBERS TO LIMIT BROADBAND
CONDUIT INSTALLATIONS TO
PROJECTS IN PRIORITY AREAS
FUNDED THROUGH THE BUDGET
DELETE PROVISIONS IN CONFLICT
WITH THE TRAILER BILL AND MAKE
FORMING CHANGES. WERE
SUBSTITUTING THE MOTION FOR
MAYBE FORTY FIVE SAID BILL
PASSES SEVEN TO ZERO AB EIGHT
SEVENTEEN SPORTS FISHING
LICENSES IS A TO PASS RECEPTION
IN THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
FORTY FIVE. TO THAT BILLS
APPROVED TO SEVEN TWO ZERO AB
EIGHT SEVEN TO LEAVE OF ABSENCE
FIREFIGHTERS. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS RECEPTION ROCKHOPPER MAYBE
FORTY FIVE SEVERAL PASSES SEVEN
ZERO. AB THIRTEEN ELEVEN
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING IS
A DO PASS RECEPTION DURING THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB FORTY FIVE
SEVERAL PASSES. SEVEN TO. THAT
INCLUDES OUR MEMBERS IN
ALPHABETICAL ORDER THE
FOLLOWING MEASURES THAT ARE ON
THE SISENSE UPON THE SUSPENSE
FILE OUR TWO YEAR BILLS THAT
REMAIN ELIGIBLE TO MOVE-
BEGINNING JANUARY IN THE YEAR
OF THE ARE IN THE SECOND
SESSION BEGINNING THE SECOND
YEAR OF THE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO LEGISLATIVE
BIANNUAL SESSION- STE- SOME OF
THEM HAVE BEEN REQUESTED BY THE
AUTHOR. SOME BY COMMITTEE AND
SOME WERE PLACED THERE BY
COMMITTEE BECAUSE OF BUDGET
IMPLICATIONS ARE IN THE BUDGET
OR CONFLICTS WITH THE BUDGET OR
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE WORKED
OUT SO I'M GONNA READ DOWN THE
LIST AND HERE WE GO. AB FOUR BY
ARAMBULA THESE ARE ALL TO YOUR
BILL CITIES BILLS ARE STILL
ACTIVE COME JANUARY. AB FOUR
ARAMBULA. AB ONE ONE SEVEN
BOERNER HORVATH AB FOUR SEVEN
ZERO CARILLO. AB ELEVEN OH SIX
CERVANTES. AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
THREE BY THE CAN FIVE K. TO
COMMITTEE BILL AB THIRTEEN CHAO
AB TEN THIRTY EIGHT GIPSON. AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT IRWIN AB
TWO FIVE SIX KALRA AB FIVE SIX
TWO LOW AB TWENTY TWO MCCARTY
AB FIVE THREE EIGHT MURATSUCHI
AB TWELVE SEVEN EIGHT. JERRY
AND I DO WANT TO MAKE ONE
COMMENT ON THAT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL CONCEPTS BUT
THERE ARE. DISCUSSIONS THAT
NEED TO GO ON AT NIGHT- THE
COMMITTEE THE POLICY COMMITTEE
THERE WERE ISSUES NOT WORKED
OUT IN THE POLICY COMMITTEE SO
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
BILL HAS TIME TO BE WORKED OUT
PROPERLY THAT'S AB TWELVE SEVEN
EIGHT. AB TWO FOUR ZERO BY
RODRIGUEZ AND AB FOUR OH FOUR
FIVE SALAS SO THOSE ARE ALL TO
YOUR BILLS THAT REMAIN ELIGIBLE
FOR ACTION COME JANUARY THAT
CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS MISTER
CHIEF CONSULTANT OFFERING ELSE
CONCLUDE YOUR BUSINESS WITHOUT
OBJECTION THIS COMMITTEE
HEARING IS ADJOURNED.